you are not the main character of your
story the reader is the main character
the moment you realize that you realize
that you are in the business of serving
the reader people don't buy the asset
right no one buys a book what the
person's buying is an answer to a
question hello and welcome back to Deep
dive the weekly podcast where every week
it's my immense privilege to sit down
with authors academics entrepreneurs and
creators and other inspiring people and
we talk about how they got to where they
are and the strategies and tools we can
learn from them to help build a life
that we love what you're about to hear
is an interview between me and Nicholas
Cole and the main theme of what we're
going to talk about is how you can make
money on the internet through online
writing you can make money as a writer
it's just you need to differentiate
between are you saying I want to write
this and then you go out into the world
and go who's willing to buy it or are
you starting in the opposite direction
and go what do you need what question do
you have and can I provide it he's done
basically everything as it relates to
making a full-time income from the
internet through writing and so in the
video we break down how to get started
with this how anyone can make money
writing on the internet how to build an
audience through writing on the internet
and lots of like super tactical stuff
further in the episodes anyone can
become a writer all of these skills are
easy to learn and it's possible you just
need to invest the time to learn some of
these skills and put them into practice
thank you so much for coming on the Pod
where this is it off this is gonna be so
fun like we've we've known each other on
the internet for the past like one year
plus I think and now you're here in
London on Thanksgiving break and here we
are on Thanksgiving recording this I'm
so I'm so happy we made it yeah thank
you so much for coming down yeah
um I was thinking like you are the kind
of I guess a professional at making
money through online writing I guess
like how how do you introduce yourself
to people these days if someone asks
like what do you do what what do you
what do you say to that I like to say I
use language to change how people think
okay so I used I used to get paid I I
frame it this way I used to get paid as
a Ghostwriter and as a ghost writer or
earlier on as a Content writer you get
paid to write words so someone's like
I'm gonna pay you to write 800 words I'm
gonna pay you to write 1200 words 1500
words and it took me a long time that
took a long time to realize that great
writers don't get paid to write lots of
words they get paid to write two or
three words that then dictate the
direction of the 800 words the 1500
words the 3000 words so now I focus on
using language to change how people
think writing two or three words that
changes the direction of which way the
wind is blowing oh okay definitely want
to dig more into that um I was thinking
we would talk about kind of a handful of
different ways to essentially become a
millionaire through online writing or
through writing of some sort and given
that you've done this in various kind of
uh fields
I feel like you'd be the perfect kind of
expert expert on the topic
um but before we go there you you have a
fantastic book
um the art and business of online
writing which I've actually ordered a
physical copy on Amazon which is
arriving tomorrow because we're showing
it off in a video like on Friday oh cool
that'll be cool um thanks for supporting
the artists no it's all good I've been
I've been recommending that book to so
many people when they ask questions like
should I start a blog and hey I want to
make money on this on internet thing but
I don't really want to show my face on
YouTube I want to become a writer
um and I just send that book to a lot of
people but in that book you talk about
your origin story which is like a World
of Warcraft Pro Gamer or something yeah
I had a World of Warcraft phase during
wrath and cataclysm as well really and
but like I I know I always like loved
the idea of being in a raiding Guild but
I could never make it work with like my
mum calling me down for dinner as a
freaking 16 year old and then having to
leave the raid and all of this kind of
stuff so what was your background in
World of Warcraft how did the origin we
had the same story first of all hoarder
Alliance oh I was bored okay good yeah
that's the the right answer
um yeah I was I you know same thing I
was a really hardcore gamer as a
teenager and I didn't know that I had
celiac disease till I was 18. so I was
really sick growing up and I also wanted
I had dreams of playing in the NHL and
fractured my spine when I was 14 and
then tried to come back to the sport
fractured it again when I was 17. so
those two things you don't have a lot of
other time or options so I just sat in
front of my computer and I got really
really good at world Warcraft right and
uh yeah by the time I finished high
school I was
you know competing at a pro level and a
lot of the guys that are at the top of
the space now are guys that I remember
playing against 10 years ago I was just
a little too early you know in 20 let's
see I was 17 2007 so that was
the very very beginning of the Esports
Trend oh okay so I missed that boat by
like 18 months yeah that was like end of
boating Crusade wasn't it because wrath
came out 2010. yeah yeah
so you would see what were you like on
the rating side or on the PVP side all
the PVP really yeah same thing I never
had time my parents you know they were
always like you have to sit and have
dinner with us you can't raid on school
nights so I would just PVP and I would
just compete against all the best
players in the world so where did the
interest in writing come in because like
journalism fiction like you must have
had some sort of background in writing
yeah I've just always had it I think my
earliest memory is my mom signed me up
for a Poetry Club when I was in fourth
grade and I don't know that I wrote
anything fantastic but there was
something really cool about that and I
don't know why like words just always
stuck I was not good in math was not
good in science I really struggled in
school but writing always made a ton of
sense
okay so you're you're at University
you're doing the you're side hustling as
a music producer you're a side hustling
a side hustling as a barista while do
while doing your degree what happened
next in the story
I sat in my last class uh of college and
the very last class I was taking
um from this professor it was kind of a
he was locally famous in Chicago he was
an author and he had written this book
called hairstyles of the Damned his name
is Joe Mino
and I loved him as a teacher he was
great and in the city everyone was kind
of like oh my dream is to write a book
like him and he kind of embodied the the
goal of being a locally famous writer at
least to me and we're sitting in the
very last class and he's like okay
everyone you're about to graduate I'm
going to tell you how to become a
successful writer so we all pull out our
notepads and our notebooks you know I'm
sitting there and I'm like this is what
it was all about I put in my time you're
going to give me the answer and he's
like okay here's what you do you spend a
year minimum on your story
and then when you're done you go down to
the bookstore and you pull these
magazines off the shelf and you look for
agents at these uh because at the backs
of magazines they'll say you know who
are the Publishers and usually who are
the agents he's like you find the
addresses of the agents that you want to
reach then you go down to UPS you get
yourself a manila envelope and you put
your story in the manila envelope and
then you put it in the mail and you ship
it to them
and then you wait
and you just wait and you just keep
waiting and then in six to 12 months
they're going to mail you back a
rejection letter and you're gonna put it
on top of your desk and that's where
you're going to stack all your rejection
letters and then you're going to do that
for 30 years and that's how you become a
successful writer
and he was serious he was like in order
to be a writer you need to get
comfortable with rejection and half the
class was just like it was like a
doomsday parade you know it's just
here's everything that's wrong with
publishing and here's why it's so hard
to make a living as a writer and
and I was sitting there and I got my
iPhone in my pocket and I'm like I have
more technology in this phone than the
Space Shuttle that we originally landed
on the moon with like how how is it that
the most effective way to make a make
money as a writer is for me to go print
off my story and then just go wait for a
rejection letter and I was Furious and
so I left school
basically being like okay thanks for
teaching me things about writing thanks
for teaching me how to read my work out
loud that was a really big thing that I
learned and I loved that but there was
no preparation on how to actually
monetize your craft and so when I
graduated I was like I'm gonna have to
go figure this out on my own and I was
talking to a friend at the time and the
question that I posed to him he was a
YouTuber as well I was a gaming YouTuber
and I was like if models and Foodies and
other archetypes have Instagram and
Gamers and you know Educators and
filmmakers have YouTube
where do writers write like what is the
writing equivalent and he said oh you
should check out this platform called
quora and coro's question answer site I
had never heard of it was 2013 and
immediately fascinated like I spent
hours reading on quora and what I
noticed is every question was the way I
saw it every question was basically a
writing prompt so it wasn't really a
question answer site it was a social
question answer site and every question
was this this jump off point and all the
highest performing quora answers were
stories so someone would be like what is
it like to be an entrepreneur and the
answer wouldn't be here's a formal
definition of Entrepreneurship right the
first sentence would be like when I was
22 I was worth eight million dollars and
six months later I was worth nothing
sleeping on my parents couch again and
you're like obviously I'm gonna read the
story right and so I had this aha where
I I noticed that I didn't have to wait
for permission anymore well my teacher
was trying to tell me and us and all
these students is there's a way that the
game is played and you have to wait for
permission or you have to you have to
have someone else give you permission
and they have to validate you and you
have to wait and you have to wait and
you have to wait and your success is
based on someone else deciding when
you're successful
and the internet made me realize well no
I don't have to wait for anyone I can
just start writing and if the quality of
my writing reaches people then we're
good to go
in that position a lot of
in that position a lot of people might
be thinking well how am I going to make
money from this like it's all well I'm
good answering free questions on the
internet I was writing on forums back in
the day but like there's no there's no
obvious path to monetization there
whereas in the at least old school
traditional Industries like publishing
it's like hey you know JK Rowling got 57
rejections or whatever it was and then
the 58th one became made her a
billionaire that kind of that kind of
model so I guess I guess how were you
thinking about the monetization were you
thinking about the monetization that
that fear of okay cool I'm writing on
the internet but like what what then
totally
um the whole time I mean I could say you
know I've been at it for 10 years now
and
the monetization question is really hard
to answer that's part of why I'm so
passionate about talking about it
because 10 years ago there weren't a lot
of resources explaining how to make
money the first so in college I started
writing my first book The the book about
being a gamer and my goal was I want to
finish this book and I kind of had the
the pipe dream that I think every writer
has where you think my first book is
going to be my magnum opus it's
immediately going to be this incredible
bestseller the world is going to notice
my talent and and you just kind of think
magically you're gonna make a ton of
money from it and I spent hours
researching about should I do
self-publishing should I try and get a
publishing deal all of this stuff
because I wanted to be educated on the
business side I didn't want to just you
know accept whatever happened and that
first book did not make me a lot of
money I had a very real moment with
myself where I spent four years writing
this book and you hit publish and then
you're like cool I made a thousand bucks
you know and then you start to realize
that the way that you're taught to think
about monetizing your writing is only
that model you know it's I hope the
world recognizes my genius you know I
don't even know what a publishing
contract is but I hope I sell enough
copies so that I just magically you know
have enough to live on and then you
start doing the napkin math and you're
like this is not going to work out the
way that I think it's going to work out
so yeah I spent a lot of time reading
forums and studying other digital
marketers and trying to understand like
what is a funnel you know what are ads
what's a landing page what's an what's a
free email course you know and just year
after year I just kind of kept piecing
all these things together learning how
to monetize
so the time you were writing on cora but
it sounds like you weren't thinking or
were you thinking that okay if I can do
well in quora sudden then then
yeah how are you thinking about the
monetization I mean in the in the very
very beginning it was uh I have no idea
I'm just gonna try stuff okay uh my
my assumption was if I get enough people
reading my work on quora something will
happen so what I did is you know because
that's the only place you can start from
right and so what I did is I challenged
myself to go okay I'm gonna commit to
this new thing I was extremely
disciplined in my 20s I still am but I
was way disciplined in my 20s and I was
uh really into bodybuilding you know I
was lifting every day I was eating six
meals a day every day I know I don't
look good anymore and uh it was
to me it was really important that if I
started something that I baked it into
my daily schedule and I did it every
single day because I knew that that was
the only way that you would really see
is it working or is it just I'm not
putting in the effort right I wanted to
run a clean experiment so I was like I'm
going to write every single day on quora
one answer a day for a year straight
worst case scenario I do the thing I
love which is right best case scenario
something happens and I had this moment
where
you know it's how it always goes where
you start a new habit and then you get
like a month in and you start getting in
your head about it and you're like I
don't know if I really want to do this
and uh and one day I was like I really
don't want to write today I I'm just
tired from my job I don't want to hit
publish forced myself to stay an extra
15-20 minutes at my job because I didn't
have internet in my apartment
I didn't allow myself to have internet
for four years until I finished writing
my book
because I knew I would waste it on
YouTube
so I removed that option and I did all
my writing at if I need to use the
internet I would just use it as coffee
shop or at work or something I wrote
this quora answer I hit publish got on
the train
and by the time I got home it was on the
front page of Reddit it was over a
million views very quickly and it was
basically my story of going from really
sick as a teenager not knowing I had
celiac disease to this bodybuilder and I
had this before and after photo uh at
the top it was a really short answer and
immediately I had I got all these emails
from people a lot of guys that looked
like me on the left hand side which was
you know skinny scrawny insecure and I
got the same two questions over and over
again what's your workout routine and
what are you eating and so I saw that
and I had this connection moment where I
was like oh a huge part of monetizing
your writing is you need to write things
that people want answers to right like
you are trading information for money at
least through the non-fiction lens
and so I spent all weekend writing these
two ebooks and on Monday I put them up
for sale I connected the website and
where I was where I was selling them to
that Viral answer that was still going
crazy on quora and I remember sitting in
my Monday morning meeting and my phone's
just going nuts with stripe
notifications and that's how I made my
first like
five grand something like that and I had
this aha moment where I was like oh you
can make money as a writer it's just you
need to differentiate between are you
saying I want to write this and then you
go out into the world and go who's
willing to buy it or are you starting in
the opposite direction and go what do
you need
what what answer are you looking for
what question do you have and can I
provide it and that was the as soon as I
realized that everything changed and I
went from the fallacy of I'm going to
sit down and write what I want to write
about now I have to go hustle it right
with starting in the inverse who's who's
the reader what do they want
I was doing a session for our YouTuber
academy yesterday where you know we were
doing like a little q a and people were
people always struggle with this
question of what's my Niche and one way
of approaching it is what do I want to
make videos about
but the more successful way of
approaching it is what do other people
want and how can I serve them yes and
just kind of thinking like an
entrepreneur rather than thinking like a
hobbyist is like hey I I have all these
I have for these hundred different
interests I want to make videos about
productivity and Entrepreneurship and
personal development like okay as do
five million other people like right
come on where's their Market where's
where is there something that we can
serve someone yeah I mean the the
hardest thing I think to wrap your head
around is your Niche is not about you
your Niche is about your reader or your
viewer or your listener so where I
notice a lot of writers go wrong is they
spend their whole lives just going well
I want to write what I want to write
about and you should
that's great but also you are in service
of the reader and I think a really
important thing to differentiate between
is
if you want to write whatever you want
to write about go for it like that's the
beauty of the internet that's the beauty
of self-publishing that's you have that
freedom but don't two seconds later then
complain when the external result isn't
what you want right so someone goes I
want to write what I want to write about
and then they go and why aren't I going
viral or where's all the money or why
don't I have a gazillion followers right
and that's because you're not being
clear about
whether you're doing this for yourself
or you're doing it for an external
outcome and I think you need to be
honest and go I want a right to make
money
great make decisions that unlock that
outcome you know whereas there's a lot
of things that I want to write in my
lifetime that I want to write and I'm
not confused about the fact that those
things are probably maybe they might be
a home run but probably not going to
make as much money as if I start with
the end in mind and go well what does
that person need and how can I use
writing to serve that need
you know what I mean there's this a
famous artist
um I don't know if you're families like
um I think uh Aziz Ansari was at a party
and he asked this
really big musician who releases stuff
like every like 10 years or something
like that and I'm blacking on the name
but but essentially he asked him like
hey man how like it seems like you just
kind of do whatever you want you just
release music when you want it seems
like you're not caught up in the
trappings of the industry like how do
you do it and the guy was like it's easy
I just make a lot less money and it's
like you know the the way we teach this
on a YouTuber Academy is I always say to
people that there is a spectrum between
I'm doing this as a hobby and I'm doing
this as a business yes where are you on
that Spectrum from like zero to ten and
everyone says ten ten ten ten otherwise
they wouldn't be in the course whereas
when we do our free workshops everyone's
like two three four is like the average
but then the same people that are like I
want to do this 10 out of 10 as a
business are still also kind of still
struggling with this thing around like
oh but I have all these 10 different
passions and I want to make videos about
all of them whereas you wouldn't make a
a grocery store well a shop trying to uh
a shop trying to sell absolutely
everything because you've been competing
with Amazon you'd be finding a niche
where you know there's there is a market
for the thing and just focusing on that
even if you have these other 10
interests yeah I mean the example I love
we use this in uh in our course ship 30
which is we asked the question
what's Ryan holiday's niche
and immediately the whole chat all blows
up with the same one word right everyone
says stoicism and then I go okay great
how do you know that
right like why did you type that and we
don't realize that we associate niches
with people because they educate us
to do that right it doesn't just happen
like the reason we associate stoicism
with Ryan holiday is because he writes
book after book after book and he makes
YouTube video after YouTube video that
says stoicism right we would not do that
if every single thing he wrote or every
video he created was a different topic
so I think that's point a point B is
realizing that you can do both I I it's
a fallacy to think you're a
one-dimensional person you're not we all
have many interests you can do more than
one thing most people don't know that I
have like I don't even know three poetry
books published no I didn't know that
yeah right most people don't know that
and that's fine because I'm not confused
about which thing I do because I want to
do it and which thing I do that is my
money maker that's the whole question is
you want to make the niche if if your
goal is how do I make money right you
want to make the niche your money maker
but that doesn't mean you can't do other
things you can just don't expect those
things to have the same external outcome
as your money maker right and I think
remembering that gives you so much
freedom and it allows you to do all the
things that you want to do and you
aren't confused about what to optimize
to make sure that you can still put food
on the table right
all right we're just going to take a
quick break from the podcast to
introduce our sponsor which is very
excitingly heal I have been a pain
customer of huel since 2017 so it's been
about six years now that I've been using
Hugh fairly regularly I started eating
Hill in my fifth year of medical school
and I've been using heal regularly ever
since because you know I like to be
productive I've you know my calendar is
full with a lot of things and often I
don't have the time or don't make the
time to have a particularly healthy
breakfast or a particularly healthy
lunch my favorite flavor is salted
caramel because 400 calories you get 40
grams of protein which is absolutely
insane and you also get a decent healthy
mix of carbohydrates and fiber and fat
along with 26 different vitamins and
minerals which are all very good for the
body there's nine different flavors of
this to choose from my favorite is a the
banana version and also the Salted
Caramel version so what I do is I take
my two scoops I put them into my
NutriBullet blender type thing although
you can just use a normal Shaker if you
want I mix it up normally with water but
a little bit of milk to add a bit more
of a milkshake like consistency to it
and then I just sip that while I'm on my
desk doing my work in the morning and it
ensures that I get a very healthy
breakfast in that's nutritionally
complete rather than some high sugar
cereal which is what I would have
defaulted to instead also heal is
ridiculously reasonably priced like a
meal 400 calories comes out to one pound
68 per meal which is super super cheap
compared to what the alternative would
be if you were ordering takeout for
example anyway if you like the idea of
getting these cheap and healthy and
nutritionally complete meals in your
diet then head over to heal.com forward
slash Deep dive and if you use that URL
heal.com forward slash Deep dive they
will send you a free t-shirt which are
quite nice and also a free kind of
shaker bottle type thing with your first
order so thank you so much Hill for
sponsoring this episode this episode is
very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the Market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want now if
you're based in the UK you might be
familiar with the concept of an Isa
which is an individual savings account
which is basically a tax-free wrapper
that you can put money in you can put 20
000 pounds in every year up to twenty
thousand pounds and it resets every
April and then all that money can grow
and it's completely tax-free for the
rest of your life and if you want to
sign up for an iso you can sign up for
one completely for free also on trading
212. so if you haven't yet filled up
your eyes allowance or at least put some
money into your Isa for this year that
might be a good step forward also very
excitingly there's a new feature that
they've added to the app which is a
daily interest on your uninvested cash
these interest rates may go up or down
over time as the economic environment
changes but the cool thing is that you
get paid out every single day if you're
into that sort of thing the app also
lets you Auto invest which is a great
thing because then you can automatically
invest a percentage of your paycheck
into the thing every month and so if you
haven't yet started when investing and
you want to give it a go then you can
download the app on the App Store and if
you use the coupon code Ali Ali at the
checkout that will give you a totally
free share worth up to 100 pounds it's
available on iPhone and Android and you
can check it out by typing in trading
212 into your respective App Store so
thank you so much trading212 for
sponsoring this episode I want to come
back to this stoicism
um stuff in a moment where I'm talking
about the field of like category design
and stuff but before we go there
um you said that
you decided every day I'm going to write
something on cora I'm going to do this
for the next year this was I guess
equivalent uh equivalent to my my thing
for YouTube which was I'm gonna make a
video every week for the next two years
and fingers crossed something will
happen but even if not like I'll learn
stuff I'm sure it'll be interesting in
some kind of ways maybe I'll get a few
sales for my medical admissions course
or something like that
having now taught like you know a couple
thousand people for YouTuber Academy and
I'm sure you've you've you know you've
done the same thing for for ship 30 the
writing course
that's a pretty unusual kind of mindset
to have like most people I know don't
have that attitude of all right I've
decided to do a thing I'm just gonna do
it every day for a year like what what
was it about you that made you more
inclined to go down that route and
anything that you would any advice you
would get for people who are struggling
with this idea of just committing to a
thing and doing it consistently well
first of all it's curiosity I think I'm
just a very curious person and I think
anyone who makes that decision is
inherently curious but really just stop
and think about it right no one paid you
to go to middle school but we all have a
lot of memories and a lot of lessons
learned from being in middle school no
one paid us to go to high school but
same thing
no one paid us to have
Hobbies growing up but yet we all look
back and are like oh I learned so much
playing a musical instrument or I've
learned so much playing a sport right we
inherently do it it's just for whatever
reason there's this fear of choosing to
do it yourself whereas when you're
younger someone else tells you you have
to do it and there's something
comforting about saying oh well someone
else told me that I had to do this and
so thus it must be the right thing right
and once you get comfortable making
those decisions yourself you realize
that there really isn't any wasted time
no one paid me to get into bodybuilding
for six years but the lessons I learned
from that
have shifted my life massively you know
no one paid me to learn classical piano
growing up but I learned a lot doing
that and so all it is is just realizing
that the outcome is positive and even if
you did it every day for a year like
extend the time Horizon your life is
long a year is not that much time right
and I think the fear that everyone has
is I'm going to waste time but then
meanwhile they're just they go right
back and they're scrolling on Twitter or
Instagram it's like you're already
wasting time
right so there's something about just
committing to the process and enjoying
the journey and trusting that whatever
skill you gain that skill is probably
going to be Universal it goes back to
what we were talking about you said
there's a theme of Gamers musicians
right getting into right well what is
that that's just acquiring other skills
it's not really the skill of being a
gamer it's not really the skill of being
a musician it's all the underlying stuff
work ethic commitment creativity right
yeah I see I see this a lot with
um
with medical students in particular
where like Medics are and I guess like
any kind of traditional career
which attracts a kind of risk-averse
kind of person who has done well in
school the attitude is always
um
how like essentially how many CV points
am I going to get for doing this thing
and
increasingly and and it's it's easy
enough in medicine because it's like
okay cool when I if I publish these two
papers then four years down the line
when I apply for residency I'll have an
extra two points on my thing and that
will give me an extra five percent boost
over the other people that maybe only
have one publication it's a very kind of
points-based like I'm doing this thing
because it will look good on my CV
further down the line type of attitude
whereas if I think of I guess kind of
the entrepreneurs and stuff that I know
they almost never had the attitude of
like this will look good on my CV it was
almost always an attitude of let me try
this out and see what happens and I'm
sure something something interesting
will happen further down the line I
can't I can't tell you what it's going
to be but we'll we'll kind of see what
happens
yeah it's
I think it's a very rare human trait to
Focus to want to focus on the skill more
than wanting to focus on the outcome
I really don't care about
a lot of outcomes I like them it it'll
be fun when I get there but I am way
more obsessed and interested in
mastering a skill or knowing that if I'm
in the same room with other people that
are mastering skills I want to know that
I am able to play at that level or that
I'm able to surpass that level for me
it's all about skill it's not about some
title because titles are worth you know
they matter for a moment
you know and then two days later
everyone's like oh that title doesn't
matter anymore right so it's not the
title that you care about
the second thing is when you're first
starting out
this is why one of the big goals that we
set for people in chip 30 and especially
after chip 30 we have kind of a
follow-on
um area called the captain stable
and we go the goal is to make your first
dollar on the Internet it's not to make
a million dollars it's just you need to
make one dollar because if you start
there the moment you feel that there's a
different direction that's possible
that's when you become excited about it
right but all if your risk averse
chances are it's just because you
haven't felt that there's another option
but the moment that you feel oh there is
another way that I can go then it just
becomes a well are you curious enough to
keep going
or not and the decision keep going or
not is a lot easier than start something
totally new or don't
hmm yeah I've been I've been doing a
bunch of
bunch of writing around this for the
book that I'm working on kind of this uh
the law of inertia like Newton's first
law of motion that you know something
something at rest continues to stay at
rest but something in motion continues
to be in motion unless acted on by an
external imbalanced force and I often
think of that when it comes to you know
struggling with procrastination or
struggling with anything that is just
like it's way harder to get started than
it is to
just keep going and so when it comes to
like procrastination hacks if I'm
struggling with it I'll literally set a
two minute timer on my phone I'm just
gonna do it for two minutes and then I
trick my brain into just doing it for
two minutes but then that extends into
hours whereas the thought of doing
something for hours then starts to feel
like a real like ah and just taking that
next step
um yeah I I really like the thing of
make make your first dollar
I think it like the the thinking about
it now like a lot of the conversations
I've had on this podcast with other with
other entrepreneurs it's like the moment
that they made their first dollar on the
Internet is the moment that changed
their life everything changed and that
was for me that was like when I was 13
and I was doing freelance web design I
was like [__] I can make money on the
internet like my PayPal account that
I've lied about my age which later got
like banned 10 years later because I had
to give him my driving license and they
said you learned about your age 10 years
ago when you were 13. that was like God
damn it
um I'm surprised you if you experienced
that so early then that you decide to go
to med school like what made you then
leave that yeah so um I decided to go to
med school I did I didn't say this in my
interview at the time but I reasoned
that everyone says university is the
best time of your life and med school is
six years rather than three so that's
cool and it was between medicine and
computer science because I was into the
cold coding e type thing but I just
thought it would be more interesting to
be a doctor who knows how to code than
to be a dude who knows how to code
um and so my plan was always like hey
let me get really good at medicine and
then
I'm sure with the coding background
something interesting will happen in the
intersection of like medicine and
Technology
um and it was only as I got kind of
further through it where I realized that
I cared a lot less about medicine and a
lot more about teaching medical students
so there's something about teaching that
really made my heart sing that like
practicing medicine never did and that's
what kind of took me down this Avenue
rather than that that's really
interesting
I feel like you kind of made that
decision then of
if I have this
not status symbol but
it's almost like an intuition on your
niche
right there's a difference between being
a coder
and being a doctor and being a coder
doctor right and it's often at unlikely
intersections that opportunity hides
that's why I love looking back on my
years as a gamer because pair almost
anything with gaming
and you have an unconventional Niche you
know and most things actually are like
that is if you take two things that
shouldn't be in the same room and you
put them together all of a sudden you've
created a new thing the problem is we
all say we want to stand out we all say
we want to be different but deep down we
all just want to fit in we all just want
to be the same right and so what's hard
about creating at unlikely intersections
is it requires you to be the first one
right and I'm sure even as you were
going through your journey or especially
when you were thinking about leaving
medicine you know there probably weren't
a lot of models to look to right which
is what makes the decision so
uncomfortable is you're like I've never
seen the thing that I'm about to do
before but that's also where all the
opportunity is yeah
yeah that's good that's a good way of
putting it because I think
yeah yeah at the time my my intuition
was very much that like
because like every everyone I knew was a
doctor and everyone I knew who was a
doctor complained about being a doctor
and I was like okay you know this this
is this is an interesting data point
um and I didn't even know that other
queries existed outside of medicine
really because you know my mom was a
doctor all of our friends were doctors
just like so so standard like amongst
the kind of people I hung out with to be
it to be a medic I was like yeah I don't
want to quit just be a doctor I want to
stand out and I was like cool let's
let's like given that medicine is like
the only thing I can really imagine
let's combine other things with that
um I think if I if I think of like if I
think to YouTube channels that have have
like really succeeded as well it's
because they've combined an a niche
interest in one thing with an interest
in another thing like the other channel
called tier Zoo which is combining
gaming with like uh ecology and
evolutionary biology to sort of gaming
esque videos around like why are snakes
overpowered and why are lions like but
why should Lions be nerfed and just
using that kind of terminology it's like
three million subscribers like this
stupidly profitable business there's no
another one Wendover Productions where
the guy's obsessed with airplanes and
like Aviation and he does explainer
videos about how airplanes and Aviation
and like the logistics of Formula One
and how what flight they're taking as
they move the and people just love that
[__] it's just like this guy's like
super obsessed with Aviation but has
combined it with an ability to write and
an ability to animate and suddenly no
one in the world is able to do that yeah
and he's carved out this Niche for
himself that's gotten like four million
subscribers on YouTube and makes a
business and it's so hard I think like
to
if yeah if I just think of the YouTube
example and I I guess maybe similar for
writing to just try and dominate a
single word category like it's really
hard to be a productivity YouTuber it's
a lot easier to be a productivity
combined with gaming combined with
health YouTuber for example yeah yeah I
mean here's another way of framing it is
which game do you want to play do you
want to play the competition work ethic
game or do you want to play the
creativity have fun
expression game and if you are trying to
compete in an existing category or
usually a single word category
all you're doing is going I'm better
than all the other people here you know
if you want to be a doctor the whole
game you're playing is I'm a better
doctor than all the other people who say
they're doctors right and that game is
predicated on work ethic long hours I'm
better than you incremental Improvement
or you can go I'm a coder doctor or I'm
an educator doctor right and you combine
it with a different category you create
a new subcategory and now you're not
playing a competition game because
everyone goes well all the doctors are
over there and you're a coder doctor so
I can't put you guys in the same room
right and when you do that that allows
you to then play a creativity game and
now you can go create all the
opportunities that you want and so it's
so simple that it's complicated you know
and it
we can make it sound simple but I
understand why people have the
hesitations they do and the fears but a
lot of those fears to me are more
underlying it's uh I want to be
different but deep down I really just
want to be the same you know I want to
stand out but deep down I really just
want to fit in and you have to overcome
that feeling
in order to play The Creation game you
know and that's really hard for a lot of
people yeah yeah it really is like I
think
I was speaking to someone earlier just
again on the on the YouTube example
because I'm just in the middle of this
course now who's like
um a lawyer like super successful lawyer
and it started a YouTube channel which
has started to get some traction and
she's like really worried like what if
people at work are going to see this and
it's like she kind of knows that like to
unlock this dream life where she can do
what she wants she needs to stand out
but at the same time it's that tension
between like oh but like I don't I don't
want my colleagues to think of me as a
loser who started a YouTube channel you
know when I had this illustrious law
career even though that's actually what
I want to do yeah how do you how do you
like I guess kind of the writers that
you coach have this kind of issue as
well how do you how do you approach
dealing with it yeah it's the same thing
we talk about in ship 30 and to me
the easiest solution is you just start
by being surrounded by other people that
are doing the same thing right there's
benefit to being I had a mentor in
Chicago who used to call it hanging
around the hoop you know you're just
going to get better if you hang around
the hoop with other people who are
getting better versus if you just try
and go do it by yourself and again we
all want to fit in so if
the underlying feeling is I want to fit
in and then you try and go do it on your
own that is a very viscerally
uncomfortable feeling right but if deep
down we all want to fit in and then you
are part of a community where everyone
is doing that thing all of a sudden
you're going to try to fit into that
Community which is going to make it a
lot easier to do the thing that you want
to do so there's something really
helpful about just being surrounded by
other people just like I'm sure you've
realized how many inflection points as
being a YouTuber came from you just
being friends with other YouTubers yeah
right there's this compounding effect
that happens and so for me whenever I'm
starting to get into something the first
thing I do is I look for where's the
hoop like where are the people because
if I just go spend time around the hoop
I'm going to get better 10 x
faster than if I just try and go do it
on my own
yeah I like that so we yeah we we talked
about kind of focusing focusing on on
the skill focusing on mastering the
skill rather than focusing on the
outcome another thing that you said when
when you were talking about
um there's I guess consistency
discipline stuff was also focusing on
enjoying the journey
um this is like my whole Spiel as well
it's just like with with anything
yeah so okay set a goal but like the
goal is kind of meaningless what matters
is just enjoying the journey along the
way
um do you have any kind of practical
tips on how one can
uh nudge themselves more towards
enjoying the journey along the way hmm
so that's a great question
um
reminding yourself of it daily you know
because I think the the crazy part is no
matter what you achieve
the day after you achieve it you're
gonna look at it and go well that was
nothing so what's next you know I still
go through that they're like I wake up
every day being like Oh I still haven't
made it as a writer I've done everything
I wanted to do
and I still feel like oh I haven't made
it as a writer you know and so
recognizing that that feeling never goes
away and taking little moments
consistently like I try to every day
remind myself dude 10 years ago you were
in a really not nice studio apartment
with like a heater from the 1960s sleep
on an air mattress with no furniture you
know I mean
remembering all the things you had to do
constantly is a really helpful way to
just stay connected to wow I'm having
I'm having the time of my life this is
amazing yeah the only thing I have I'll
I'll show you after this just on my
computer monitor is a little Post-It
note saying remember to enjoy the
journey smiley face and it's weird but
like just
a little reminder like that when I see
it in my profile Vision oh yeah it's
just like a little a little reminder
that encourages me to actually try and
enjoy the present moment and not just be
so fixated on on the goal at the other
end yeah and it and just always
remembering that again it doesn't matter
what you achieve it's never going to be
enough you think it will it it won't and
the goal post keeps moving over and over
and over again
so get comfortable with it nice okay so
we're back to this weekend you've been
you've written your ebooks overnight
around a bodybuilding routine and like
nutrition routine and like the next day
you just made 5K over the weekend how
did how did that feel at the time and
like what happened next it was game over
after that that was the beginning of the
end I started tracking all my income
before that I hadn't done that you know
you just show up to work and you're like
I get my paycheck I started tracking my
income outside of work so I was like
what's my side hustle making me and it
took me a while you know I think from
the time I started tracking my income it
probably took me about a year maybe a
year and a half to
build that trust with myself you know
because that's really where the fear is
you go well that's great I just made a
thousand bucks or a couple thousand
bucks but can I do that consistently
that's the real question before you can
quit your job and go do something else
so I kind of pieced together a couple
side hustles and
I wanted to gather data to go okay for
six months can I prove that I can
consistently generate a certain amount
of income outside of my job and once I
got around 50 of my monthly paycheck
I was like I bet if I had eight more
hours in the day because I was only
doing this you know at night a couple
hours if I had eight more hours in the
day could I fill in the other 50 that
was that was the bet I was making and I
was like yeah I think I can and so in
2016 same day I published my first book
actually so book goes live and it was my
last day of work which is really cool I
didn't mean for that to happen just
happened and uh and I left my job and
two weeks later I freaked out because I
you know you don't have a paycheck hit
your bank account and you're like oh
I need to I need to start making some
money here or I'm not going to pay my
bills and my burn rate was super low I
was living in a really
you know run-down apartment in Chicago
and you know it's not like I was living
lavishly at all
um and that's how I fell into ghost
riding it was my first my very first
like real paid writing opportunity after
I quit my job was a ghostwriting okay
that brings us very nicely to our five
different ways to make a million dollars
as a writer
um what were your like what side hustle
income was getting you to this 50 point
while you were still working the big one
was uh in end of 2015 I want to say
maybe early 2016 uh so I a little
backstory in 2015 2016 Cora had a really
cool partnership with all of the major
Publications so they partnered with like
ink Forbes Fortune time CNBC all of
these and what they were doing is they
had a team
that would crawl really great quora
answers and then they would pitch the
quora answers to the major Publications
and I figured this out and I spent
I don't know 20 30 hours going through
quora and just researching what are all
the things most likely to get
republished like what's the the signal
for CNBC is going to take a core answer
you know and I I mean I basically came
up with uh well here's what they're
looking for here's the type of topic
here's the structure a lot of them just
wanted listicles you know and I started
deliberately writing my quora answers in
that style so I was like that's the goal
you know and again to what end I didn't
know I was just curious and I was like I
bet if I get a bunch of core answers
republished something will happen you
know so I started writing in that style
and I
I'm pretty sure I set the record in 2015
2016 for like the most core Answers
republished by other major Publications
in a year I had dozens and dozens and
dozens and I got them in every major Pub
and there was a point where Inc magazine
was republishing one of my core answers
every week for like months and so I
ended up getting a column with them and
how their columns worked they changed it
but back then how their columns worked
is you'd get paid per page view so
they'd pay you like a penny per page
view and to me this was the mechanism
that never existed right for writers
there is no YouTube and AdSense so I was
like okay that's fair you're gonna pay
me per page view if I can bring you
traffic I'm gonna get paid and I had
already figured out how to write viral
core answers so I was like okay game on
like let's play and they gave me this
column and they were like hey can you do
like two to four columns per month and I
literally came back and I was like can I
do One A Day
like I will write 30 columns for you a
month because I want to generate enough
page views so that I can make enough
money to quit my job and they were like
you're nuts but sure and I did it and
literally every single day for a year
and a half I wrote an ink magazine
column like insane level of output and I
was still writing on quora
and I suppose while you still have the
job while I still had the job so I was
this was like
approaching Peak it got even crazier in
ghost riding after but like this was
approaching the peak of what I could
handle in a day or a week in terms of
writing and
I ended up bringing in like millions and
millions and millions of page views for
them and it amounted to roughly I mean
it's funny to look back on now but
I forget how the math worked out in
terms of page views but I probably was
making three to five grand a month
writing for ink and you know I wasn't
making that much as a entry-level
copywriter so that was like 50 of my
paycheck and so once I had that I was
like okay if I had eight more hours in
the day my thinking was could I write
two columns a day you know what I mean
like I was like could I just double the
input and double the output
um so that was how I was making half my
salary
that's really cool that's
there were easier ways to do it looking
back but it was uh it was an interesting
mechanism at the time
to what extent were is it a bit of
random question but to what extent were
these were these like Evergreen content
or like was this literally a trade of
time for money or was it actually a
trade of because I feel like the moment
you decorate your income from your time
input that's another inflection point
that changed the game for a lot of
people yes that didn't come until way
later
um
it there so I thought that there would
be a compounding effect I thought as my
library grows there will be some
Evergreen effect and then my average
monthly page views will go up and it did
my average did go up a little bit but it
was not there was no inflection point
and so in order for me to keep earning
three four five grand a month I needed
to be churning out
20 30 40 columns a month so
there was a while like it was until I
got into ghost writing which was still
trading time for money it's just it was
a premium on my time right but that
inflection point didn't come till later
oh okay all right so you're you see your
day job which I don't think we mentioned
it you were doing copywriting for an ad
agency yeah what is copywriting I only
recently real like I was so confused
like like a copyright with a W versus
copyright with the rht yeah just like
yeah copywriting with the w is and
there's different uh definitions for it
my job at the time was I was doing like
all the work that nobody wanted to do
you know I was
writing social media copy for Brands I
was proofreading proposals to try and
land new clients like anything with
writing in this agency is what I was
responsible for doing
as a small agency
the real definition of copywriting is
normally in the context of sales copy so
you're specifically writing things
with the goal of selling a product or
selling a service yep so you're writing
landing pages or you're writing emails
or
whatever it is and there's a very
specific
I don't even know if you call it style
but there's like rules to copywriting
and sales copywriting and things that
you need to do you know biggest thing is
benefits not features you know even that
most people don't know don't talk about
what you do talk about what you're going
to unlock for the reader for the
customer whoever so my job quote unquote
as a copywriter was very basic it was
just sales copy proofread or um social
media copy proofreading stuff like that
ah okay and how much were you earning at
the date of oh man like maybe 45k a year
salary I mean it was not a lot yeah
and so when you started earning the sort
of three to five k month from Inc
magazine that was
yeah I guess like 50 of your yeah your
thing and I didn't spend any of it I
didn't upgrade my life I didn't go buy
new clothes I didn't I just saved it
because I wanted that as Runway you know
I wanted to when I quit my job know that
worst case scenario I was good for like
three months four months
you know so each of these were like very
deliberate decisions along the way but
none of it was rash it's not like I was
jumping out the window going oh I just
magically hope this all works out like
it was always the next logical step and
and I tried to minimize the risk as much
as possible
we're going to take a very quick break
from the podcast to introduce our
sponsor brilliant.org I've been using
brilliant for a few years now and it's a
fantastic online platform for courses in
maths and science and computer science
now one of my life philosophies is that
we should all Endeavor to be lifelong
Learners if we want because it's good
for the mine it's good for the body it's
good for our general happiness and
health and Brilliant is a perfect
resource from this because you can
really level up your own thinking in
terms of maths and science and computer
science without having to spend hundreds
of thousands of dollars on extra degrees
or extra courses now the courses are
brilliant are actually great because
they take what could be dry Topics in
math and science and computer science
and they turn them into really
interesting interactive and enjoyable
kind of experiences where you learn a
little bit and then you apply it in
practice and then you learn a bit more
and then you put it into practice and
it's almost like the system that we used
to use in our tutorials back when I was
at University of Cambridge where you
would learn a little thing and then
you'd be paired with a world-class
expert in the thing and they'd be asking
you questions and you'd be kind of
figuring it out together rather than
being spoon fed information like we're
normally taught in school each lesson on
brilliant is broken up into 15 minute
bite-sized chunks and so wherever you
are in your day you can find a little
bit of time you can go on the app and
you can level up your brain rather than
scrolling social media or whatever the
other default activity might be and it's
pretty cool as well because they're
constantly updating the library of
courses for example they've recently
released a course introduction to
algebra and this is like a visual
representation of algebraic thinking now
I thought I understood algebra because I
did maths in school but actually the way
that brilliant explains it with kind of
the stories and the puzzles and the
interactive exercises you go along it's
really given me a new understanding of
algebra that I just didn't have before
and that maybe you would need to do like
a math degree to actually get that grasp
of what algebra actually is and why it's
so important so if any of that sounds
uphill straight and you'd like to level
up your thinking and your knowledge in
maths or science or computer science
then head over to brilliant.org forward
slash deep dive and the first 200 people
to click that link which will be in the
show notes and in the video description
as well will get 20 off the annual
premium subscription so thank you so
much brilliant for sponsoring this
episode and let's get right back to the
podcast let's say someone's listening to
this and they're thinking I wanna I
wanna Moonlight as a Ghostwriter what is
it like what does it physically look
like is it like if you find a client and
then you hop on a zoom call with them
and be like hey what do you want to
write about like how does it work yeah
so there's a ton of nuance obviously but
the simplest way to explain it is
recognize that anyone with a business or
anyone with a fund or anyone with a
profitable product
wants to share who they are on the
internet because if they build an
audience they are going to attract more
opportunity right or they're going to
sell more of their product or service so
first of all recognizing that potential
ghost writing quote unquote clients are
everywhere they exist everywhere anyone
with a big YouTube channel probably
needs to go try it anyone with a big
podcast probably needs a Ghostwriter
anyone with a company probably needs a
Ghostwriter you know and it's becoming
less and less stigmatized like the same
way that you go I want to make videos
I'm going to hire a video editor well
writing's the same way you're like I
want to write tweets LinkedIn posts
articles newsletters whatever you're
like I need a writer you know so that
stigma doesn't really exist anymore or
less and less
the what it actually looks like is you
just get on the phone with the person or
get on Zoom or whatever and you just go
okay
let's forget the Whole 30 000 foot
strategy like this one thing what do you
want to say
like just one it's a tweet it's a thread
it's an article I always tried to remind
people like we're not gonna figure out
your entire life mission here right that
will reveal itself yep you know a mentor
had a great quote which is
um you can't steer a stationary ship
right if you're just sitting at your
desk and you're just looking out into
the world you can anticipate it all you
want but the moment that ship leaves the
harbor if it starts raining your your
plan is out the window right so I would
say that to these people over and over
again and be like the the end will
reveal itself for now let's just focus
on what is the one thing you want to
write and all you're doing is just
hurting their thinking you know you're
just kind of whittling it down
um getting clear on what it is that they
want to say in this one piece and the
process that I did is I would take the
phone call I would record it and I would
use this website called rev which allows
you to transcribe things I would get the
transcript and I liked to think of ghost
riding myself as I'm not writing I'm
I'm deleting so you have a you have a
transcript and they're giving you all
the information and your job isn't
really to sit down and recreate it your
job is to remove all the tangents and
all the fluff and all the things that
don't have to do with the one thing that
they're trying to say and then you're
just using their words and reorganizing
it that's the way I liked thinking of
ghost writing and
it's a skill but if you can get good at
it I mean you can make a killing
yeah like it's only it's only recently
this that there's been so like I work
with a Ghostwriter for like LinkedIn
posts and stuff because it's like
I want to convert my videos where I've
already said this stuff into tweet
threads and Linkedin posts but I sure as
hell don't want to do that myself so
like cape who wants to who wants to help
out with this and now that I've kind of
seen what that process of working with a
Ghostwriter is like I'm just kind of
thinking like
one of the
one of the ultimate side hustles these
days is to be is to be a video editor
because now having tried hiring video
editors it's just an absolute Nightmare
and most people are well suck at it and
if someone just took my skillshare class
over a weekend they could become like
really good at video editing I was like
what why don't more people do this if
anytime people email me and be like hey
I'm a student and I want to make money
on the side was like video editing is
like a good starting point teach
yourself the skill
find find YouTubers who need editing
because they all do especially like
podcasts everything except like content
stuff but increasingly I'm starting to
say to people it's like hey you've got
two options video editing or writing
like actually if you can if you are good
at writing like if you're a student and
you've written essays and you can
appreciate what like blog post writing
is compared to essay writing there's
like zillions of like the local
orthodontists the local lawyer the local
accountant they all need ghostwriters
way more so than video editors actually
and it's just it seems like an
incredible opportunity it's yeah it is
incredible and to be honest it's even
I even think it's even easier now than
even five six seven years ago when I was
getting into it which is
just think about how many creators there
are
and how the whole game if you are a
profitable Creator if you have some sort
of business or product or service
connected to the to your creation
attention engine right
you need to scale yourself on the
internet with words
fifty percent of it could either be
video audio and the other 50 is actual
words and language and so the lowest
barrier to entry is a writer going to
Someone Like You and going I'm going to
take your entire Archive of YouTube
videos you've already done the work and
I'm going to extract all of the written
content that you haven't created yet
right and so as a Ghostwriter it's
almost like humbling yourself and
realizing you aren't getting paid to sit
down and like be brilliant and quote
unquote ghost write or ghost think right
you already did the thinking The Ghost
Writer just needs to go through your
library and go I'm going to scale you
with words and you can make six figures
doing that
from your you know bedroom and your
sweatpants I mean that is not a hard job
to get and the way I like to frame it to
people is
the easiest and fastest way to do it is
to do it for free first
go find a Creator go find an
entrepreneur go find someone that you
think should be scaling themselves with
words on the internet and go I'll do
your first week of content for free I'll
write 10 threads for you for free I'll
write five blog posts for you for free
if you can do it well that person will
throw money at you yeah absolutely right
I'm thinking if someone emailed me and
was like I I see you've got these 13
skillshare classes your how to study
should be an ebook
I've written the first five chapters for
you I'd be like oh my God like join my
team full time I will do whatever it
takes to hire the hell out of you and
like no one has ever done that yes
exactly it's so easy and so funny story
I went back to uh I went back to my
college maybe like
five years ago at this point right out
it was
six to 12 months after I quit my job and
I went back to my school and I was
meeting up with a professor and I saw
another professor down the street and he
happened or down the the hall and he
happened to be teaching a class at the
time and he was one of my professors and
it was a small class 15 students and he
was like Hey as long as you're here why
don't you come talk to the class share
some of your Lessons Learned because he
had kind of seen some of my internet
writing and was like oh wow there's
starting to be some traction here and I
go in front of the class and he's like
all right Cole why don't you tell
the aspiring writers here how they can
start making money from their writing
and I literally said
don't start by trying to make money from
your writing do it for free and everyone
in the class looked at me like I was
crazy and my teacher jumped in and he
was like well no no I think what Cole's
trying to say is you know uh charge your
worth you know charge like an hourly
rate or something and I was like no that
is not what I'm saying I'm saying start
for free prove you can do it and then
the opportunities will just waterfall
all over you and the problem with the
reason people don't do that is because
they're so afraid that they're going to
get taken advantage of they're so afraid
that
um like they're doing something wrong
when really if you offer to do something
for free what you're doing is you're
removing all the friction if someone DMS
you and goes I want to write for you but
this is how much it costs you now have
to allocate time and mind share to think
about whether or not that's a good idea
right which you don't have the time to
do any successful person doesn't have
time to do that at least on command
right but you can easily remove all that
friction by just going hey I already see
what you're doing I've already consumed
30 hours of your content I've already
extracted these five threads and these
five blog posts for it I want you to
read it here you go if you don't have
time to read it pass along to your team
and if you want more of it let me know
made this would be like literally my
dream come true if anyone wants to DME
with that exact message and this is this
is what people don't understand is that
the free work the ROI like I'm cheering
up at the thought of like how incredible
it would be if someone actually did that
and and the amount of emails I get from
people being like bro what's the best
business idea I'm like God damn it
exactly and what what people don't
realize is I still do this yeah like I
still when I meet the right person I
still go you know what
don't don't pay me for that even though
I know that they've got the money and I
know that I'm worth the money and they
know I'm worth the money I still in the
right circumstance go you know what
don't pay me for it I'll do it for free
six months ago
I met a guy really successful
entrepreneur and investor and he wanted
help writing uh his speech he was giving
a commencement speech
and I was like I could either charge
money for this now or I can do this for
free and I can call in a favor later
and I chose free because I knew oh okay
you know what I see all these other
outcomes that I could get later
and I bet if I do this for you for free
you are going to constantly think about
ways to pay me back right because that's
how that type of person thinks and I the
reason I still make that decision is
because people don't realize that the
ROI on free work is exponential whereas
the ROI on paid work is not exponential
it's just fixed it's like hey I'll pay
you five grand right but I've done so
much free work for people over the years
that that's why my network is the way
that it is because people go well I
remember when you helped me write my
commencement speech so what do you need
trying to raise money here's 10 people
you know you try and do this here's the
right person to talk to you're trying to
you have a question about that you
should go talk to that person me it's
game changing advice like the ROI on
free work I was thinking like I was I
was saying this to a friend a friend the
other day like I've I've worked with
like of the various coaches I've worked
with two two come to mind one and like
they're both people I knew like through
the network who were who were getting
into coaching and one offer to do it for
me for free and the other one charged me
for it and the one who offered to do it
for free I have sent so much [__] his
way so much traffic plug this course
whenever he's doing a course plugged all
of his stuff because I feel this
profound sense of like
like even though I could have I could
have easily afforded it and I knew he
was worth it like we we knew what was
going on there but like the fact that he
offered to do it for free may make me
makes me feel so indebted to him whereas
the friend of mine who charged me for
coaching when he asked me to plug his
stuff and be like kind of it's just it's
just I mean even even though he's a
friend it's a bit it feels a bit more
totally yeah weird and a bit more
transactional and I'm like well I mean
wait I could charge 20K for a sponsored
video like
etc etc and here's here's the exactly
and here's the thing is it often
translates into paid work right if you
start for free it doesn't take very long
for the person to go this is amazing yep
now I I want to pay you right they will
throw money at you and that's the point
is like if you can prove that you can do
it
the money is easy but if you can't do it
and they're not happy with the free work
then you shouldn't be charging for it in
the first place right so it's it's a
uncomfortable forcing function for you
to learn am I creating something for the
for this person that's worth being paid
for and if it's not you have more work
to go do more free work to get your
skill up right and if it is they throw
money at you yeah that's it's like it's
it seems like it's the longer road but
it is the shortcut because it's the
forcing function for your skill and the
skill is the hard part
yeah no absolutely like I'm just the
sort of so many dots are connecting like
in my mind like um one thing that I've
kind of been saying to uh kind of team
members of mine who are now getting into
like YouTube Consulting and stuff on the
side it's almost just like hop in a free
call and give as much value as you
possibly can on that free call and I
guarantee at the end of it they're gonna
say how can I how can I hire you for
this thing and a lot of them are like oh
but like should I charge I was like no
no free call just give as much value as
you possibly can similarly uh my old
housemate
um used to kind of help me out with like
businessy type stuff and she then met a
few kind of massive YouTubers and helped
them be like oh you know let's draw an
org chart let's like see how you're
going to run the business and they were
like [__] like this this person's
incredible I want to hire you for like
whatever what whatever amount of money
you want and it's just it's just amazing
how much people who are profitable and
successful with from will throw money at
people who are good because it's so hard
to find people who are good at a thing
and can demonstrate that they're
actually good at the thing yes
um that's why so we talked about you
make a million dollars as a Ghostwriter
and I with uh when I had my agency I
mean we scaled that up to several
million in revenue and that was
um
we did it the hard way like we made so
many mistakes and the pricing should
have been so much better and like there
if I could go back that business could
have been so much more profitable than
it was but it was my first company and I
made every mistake in the book but the
second one that now we're talking about
is
um productizing yourself so so turning
your knowledge in whatever domain and
using writing as the ability to scale
yourself and productize yourself so we
did this with ship 30 for 30 which is
our course right so it's all the things
that I and my business partner Dickie
talk about in terms of writing and then
we scale it through an education course
that's writing based you know you can
also do that with ebooks and you can do
that with other assets but the goal is
instead of providing whatever you're
doing as a service so being like I'm
going to be a Ghostwriter for you or I'm
going to be a consultant for you or a
editor for you right it's all one to one
it's you're you're using time as your
measure now you're just packaging it
digitally and that allows you to scale
it the the beauty of productizing your
service is that you like we were talking
about earlier you're removing the
constraint of uh being paid for time
that's the whole that's like the biggest
challenge is as long as you're being
paid for your time and not the outcome
it's really hard to have some sort of
exponential jump in income you need to
divorce the two yeah but I guess like
you know it's it's very useful to start
up being paid for your time because I
think another mistake people make is
jumping to let me create a course and
it's like uh No One's Gonna buy it like
and that's that's why one of the things
that I often encourage is start by
providing a service so it's like start
for free prove you can do it when you
can do it people will pay you trust that
that will happen and they'll pay you
well for it and then use the paid work
to learn what questions do people have
what problems are they facing what are
your unique Frameworks for solving those
problems right once you get paid to
learn all of those things then when you
go to productize yourself you are you're
not sitting in a room going well how do
I magically come up with all these
answers right you already got paid to do
it so now you're just transforming your
service into a digital product and the
whole model for this yes going back to
free work is give away 99 of what you
know for free right what the mistake
everyone makes is they go
I'm going to productize myself and
before I tell you anything you have to
pay for it well it's the same mistake as
providing a service right you don't walk
up to someone and go hey before you know
what I can do here's how much it costs
they're like get out of here but if you
start by going here's everything here's
here's here's how to think about it
here's how to solve the problems here's
the interesting Frameworks the frames
the frame the solutions here's
everything you need to know the person
then goes well if all the free stuff was
so great then what's in the paid stuff
right and what most people don't realize
is most courses most books most uh like
paid membership communities all that you
aren't really buying information
what you're buying is implementation
you're buying accountability you're
buying access to the person that you
want to learn from so you can use all
the information in your course as your
free content it's just when someone pays
they're not buying just the information
right it's that you packaged it you're
saving them time you're giving them
access to you you're answering their
questions that's what someone's paying
for
um
yeah I think one of the one of the
things that people seem to struggle with
in this is like thinking
thinking like I don't phrase it's like
almost like thinking like a consumer
rather than thinking like a business
totally kind of thing where I where I
see this where
like just that thing we were talking
about earlier about how someone like me
will literally throw money at anyone who
is good who's demonstrated the ability
to do the thing that's like unfathomable
for people that don't have a business
because it's like well of course I'm
going to kind of try before I I like I
mean like it's just a very kind of
individual way of valuing money which
which tends to be very very price
sensitive and not appreciating what the
ROI is for someone someone with a
business totally and similarly when we
sell our YouTuber course people tell us
it's like it's it's too cheap because a
business or a brand for whom that's like
Pocket Change Is Almost gonna think it's
like the scammy because it's so cheap
even though we charge several thousand
dollars for it and so just the way an
individual values money versus the way
business values money or someone who is
already making money just is just
completely Worlds Apart this is this is
on my later list you know a book I want
to write at some point yeah is the
different ways that people think about
money and how quote unquote successful
people think about money and and I want
to help educate other people on the
different ways that people who make
money think about money in the sense
that when you go to start a business or
you pitch your services as a freelancer
you need to understand that the person
you're talking to
thinks about money totally differently
than you do right like now that I have
made some money
the way I look at money is totally
different you know and I make decisions
not on oh how much does it cost I make
decisions around well how much time is
that going to save me you know or a
really great one is you know when I was
broke
I would look at like a five thousand
dollar a month Service as oh that's so
expensive you know but then as soon as
you have a business a business that's
doing a million two million three
million four million right you start
looking at the 5K a month as a
negligible expense and you don't realize
that when you're starting out yeah right
because to when when you're living in
the rundown apartment you're like 5K a
month is a lot who would spend that
right and same thing with now
restaurants it's like I noticed that my
default if I'm in a new city and I'm
looking for a restaurant what's the
first thing that I do I pull up Google
and I sort by most expensive right
because there's a there's like a a bias
of well if it's more expensive it's
probably better right so if you're
pitching your services and you're
pitching them at a discount the person
that you're trying to sell to is like
I don't want the Honda Accord I want the
Ferrari right so it's it's all these
very interesting ways of thinking about
money that I it takes a while to see it
from the other side
yeah yeah I think one of the one of the
ways that I often think is like these
days is just in terms of uh sort of very
back of the envelope Roi calculations
like
I I booked a flight last night
um I'm going to Pakistan in the new year
for a cousin's wedding and the economy
class flight was 200 pounds and the
business class flight was 3 000 pounds
but doing the business class flight
would allow me to leave a kind of team
annual planning thing an extra two hours
later and I was like 100 valuable
because me being there with a team of 13
people or for to give two hours more
input on vision and direction of the
business is worth way more than 2 800
pounds hell yes that's a great example
that's something I just would not would
not be even able to Fathom had I not
were I not running a business because
it's like why the hell would anyone
spend 3K on a flight well you could
spend 200 for exactly the same thing
totally that's like you know the value
of money is just completely completely
changes yeah where are you staying do
you have access to Internet or not does
that allow you to work yes or no you
know can you make use of your time by
meeting someone else there there's so
many other things that have to do with
the decision than just the price tag the
price tags often like the easiest part
that's not what people get caught up on
it's how much every every single go
trading client that I had
it wasn't the price they would ask me
how much time is this gonna consume of
mine yeah so if I pay you three grand a
month four grand five grand a month do
you need an hour of my time or do you
need 20 hours of my time that is the
decision it's not the amount of money
and again that takes that's really hard
to wrap your head around when you're
especially when you're first starting
out yeah and you're trying to charge for
things like you you can't understand
that decision
yeah like uh so I'm I'm kind of seeing
this from the other side now that very
like various people on our team are
doing this side hustling stuff and they
all like say to me that oh my God like
kind of just speaking speaking to people
with businesses just makes me realize
just how differently they think about
money and how differently I think about
money and now what they do you know one
of our one of our ghost writers is like
he the the way he negotiated a pay rise
was basically being like this thing does
not require any input from you beyond
like 10 minutes a week you never need to
check the things no one ever complains
that this was not written by you like
this is saving you a lot of time and I
was like sure let's 3x your thingy which
was what he was asking for because it
was still totally worth it yeah so yeah
amazing segue so we talked about ghost
writing yeah we talked about uh
productizing yourself so third being
sales copywriting so the beauty and how
you can make a lot of money as a sales
copywriter
is you want to div again you want to
divorce being paid for the effort versus
the outcome yeah so there's a lot of
copywriters sales copywriters that get
paid like per asset you know so they go
hey I want to charge you know five grand
to rewrite your landing page or I want
to charge you you know 10 grand to redo
your email course or whatever and you
can easily make six figures doing that
how you break into upper six figures
seven figure plus territory is you have
to not be compensated for the effort but
for the outcome that you drive how does
that work so for example the way that a
lot of uh really successful sales
copywriters structure their deals is
they go okay let's take a product or
let's take an existing funnel
here's the average amount of Revenue
that you're doing right now if I can
write things that lift the revenue 25 50
I get a piece of that so now you're
being compensated on the outcome you
drive not on the I spent 20 hours
rewriting the landing page right because
if I know how there's I mean what's the
grade is it the Picasso story where he
sees the woman in the park and she's
like yeah draw something for me and you
draw something on the napkin and then
she goes how much should I pay you for
that and he goes 10 grand she goes what
it took you two minutes you know and he
goes yeah but it took me a lifetime to
learn how to draw like this right so if
I'm being paid to drive an outcome it
shouldn't matter whether it takes me 20
hours or two hours I want to be
compensated on the outcome that I drove
not on the effort and so that's how a
lot of especially really legendary sales
copywriters Gary Halbert
um
Eugene Schwartz like all these guys how
they made their fortunes was they would
take a piece of The Upside that they
unlocked for the business or the product
yeah and it's not worth it for the
business like if someone again like like
at the moment when we do landing pages
and stuff we do it per like effort kind
of unit but if someone were to be like
hey look I will measure your conversion
rate and or whatever and I'm gonna aim
to double that and I want like 10 of The
Upside I'd be like hell yes like exactly
of course that's a trade I'm making any
day of the week because it's the exact
same thing as a salesperson yeah right
you go hey based on how much new Revenue
you bring in we're gonna give you a
commission yeah so you as a writer are
basically being paid as a quote-unquote
infinitely scalable salesperson and if
you can write things that prompt people
to
purchase or take an action you should be
rewarded for the fact that you unlocked
that outcome how does how does one get
good at becoming a sales copywriter I
mean like anything you do it a lot but
um
study the greats you know I mean there's
a lot of really amazing sales
copywriters over the years my personal
favorites Gary Halbert I like I like
saying Gary is
what Hemingway would have been if
Hemingway had gotten into advertising
okay him and Hemingway have very similar
terse minimalist Styles right but
Hemingway went the novel route and Gary
Halbert went the I'm gonna sell products
route
um and also try and sell something
yourself
like the fastest way you're going to
learn is when you start writing things
that prompt people to buy and when you
notice oh when I wrote this no one
bought and when I wrote this some people
bought right that your subconscious is
going to soak up all of those lessons
and you're gonna start to piece together
your own framework on well how do I get
people to buy
okay sales copywriting um so you said
that kind of your first year as a ghost
over your first few months as a ghost
writer you were up to like 250k a year
but then you said like that kind of
changed and like what what happened at
that point so now I like to I I call it
the valley of death for uh Freelancers
who want to build agencies so what
happened was I got up to
maybe like 20 or 30k a month uh as a
Ghostwriter and I I mean I was working
four hours a day talking to really smart
people making way more than I was making
as a full-time employee and having a
blast like it was best case scenario and
I was talking to a close friend of mine
and I told him what was going on and he
was like we should turn this into a
business you know think about what
you're doing we can break it apart so
we'll have editors who talk to the
clients and we'll have writers who do
the writing he said I will train the
editors and I'll do the phone calls he
was in sales and you know that was a
great skill for him yeah and he's like
you'll do the writing and you'll train
the writers
and in about 18 months we scaled that
from me and him on his apartment couch
to more than 20 full-time employees
couple million in revenue and like 80
plus concurrent clients and we had I
mean just CEOs of publicly traded
companies grammy-winning musicians New
York time best-selling authors like all
over the board and in every industry and
the problem was
ghostwriting is such a subjective skill
you know you're not selling plastic
widgets you're you're writing something
that the person on the other side goes I
want to put my name on that yeah that
reflects me and the misunderstanding
that people have is ghost riding is
often not ghost thinking yeah right so
these people aren't saying think for me
they're saying I have my ideas I just
need you to clean it up and scale it
right and that was a very challenging
business because
we first of all everyone is full-time
everyone was on salary there was no
contractors so we had a ton of overhead
um and even though we have we had no
problem attracting and getting clients
it was the the business was unstable in
the sense that
clients would churn but the overhead was
fixed yeah so you constantly needed to
be filling up the bucket faster than the
water was coming out and and it was no
problem when it was a small agency and
it was five people but the more that we
tried to scale right your sales machine
needs to get more and more powerful in
order to do that and so the reason I
call it the value of death is there's
this there's this Gap where
a freelancer Ghostwriter or a very small
agency so from I'll call it like a
quarter million to maybe a million in
Revenue right perfect yeah right perfect
like just enough clients just enough
demand for you uh just enough take home
income to be worth your effort but then
between a million and like
I'd say the real number is like 8
million yeah
that is the value of death and your
margins go down your profitability is
down right you're you're taking out less
and less cash of the business the sales
machine is needs to get more and more
powerful and basically the net of it is
if you can't get to 10 million plus your
agency is gonna just make you gray and
unhappy and I saw it everywhere every
agency owner I talked to it was like
they were you know just their whole life
was a mess and gray hair and disheveled
and stressed they were all in the valley
of death and I ultimately came to the
same realization we got a two and a half
three years in and I was stressed out in
my mind and there was a point where I
ended up in the hospital with shingles
because I was so stressed and I was on
painkillers and on antibiotics in my bed
interviewing like the next two full-time
people in the next full two full-time
people and I was just I'd had enough and
I had this talk with my co-founder and
we were like
let's be done let's just fire everybody
go back to just you and me we had been
paying ourselves half of what I was
making before you know we were in the
Valley of Death yeah and I was like I'm
done and so uh very weirdly six months
before the pandemic we let everyone go
we scaled the business back to just us
too and then the pandemic hit you know
five six months later and
if we hadn't made that decision the
business would have been dead for sure
have you have you come across a guy
called Daniel Priestley
he's written a book called
oversubscribed and key person of
influence and like stuff the name rings
a bell but that's familiar so we had all
the Pod um a few months ago and he's
actually in London as well and and he's
become a friend a friend and Mentor he
has a a model that's almost identical to
yours just coming at it a different way
the way he phrases it is that kind of
zero to three people is like okay
whatever three to twelve people that's
where you're you're either a struggling
Boutique or you're a lifestyle Boutique
and the difference there is if you have
100K per Revenue a 100K Revenue per
employee you're a lifestyle business
you're like living the dream fun Freedom
flexibility so from like 300K to 1.2
million if you have three to twelve
people and then for him 12 to 40 people
is the desert where companies go to die
yeah where you're too big to be small
and too small to be big and Beyond 40
people it's like okay now you're in
performance business territory where
you've already got all the systems and
processes and blah blah blah blah but if
you're optimizing for fun free Freedom
flexibility cap your team size at 12.
and what we have found is that when we
had like 18 to 20 full-time employees it
was a nightmare now that we have 12
full-timers and everyone else is a
contractor it's such a breath of fresh
air I feel like I have zero stress I
spend all my time just writing writing
or filming or doing podcasts which is
what I love and zero percent of my time
in meetings but there was something
magical about something like magically
bad about having kind of 18 to 20
full-time employees where everything
just felt like it was going to [__] yes
and that seems to mirror your experience
as well it's the same thing and you know
it's kind of a a whole separate nuanced
conversation but
oftentimes
so I'll say I'll speak for myself the
mistake that I made was I equated
success with head count
so to me it was like my ego
I was proud of myself when I said oh we
have 15 full-time employees we have 20
full-time we have 23 full-time you know
and you start to realize that hey that's
a horrible measure of success because
you're literally bragging about the fact
that your overhead is going up and your
profitability is going down yeah so
that's I don't know what I was thinking
but the more important thing is
when you're focused on head count or you
think about hiring in terms of roles
most people start from the perspective
of okay I need a project manager I need
a social media manager I need a whatever
right so they think of the role the more
effective way of thinking about it is
what is the task
what is the lever
that you need and is that directly
correlated to growth in the business so
are you a revenue critical employee or
no and the mistake that I found we were
making
was we were adding all these employees
that even though they yes they like had
things to do
they weren't Revenue critical you know
and that's that's where things start to
fall apart is you you start looking for
roles or you assume that each role is a
full-time thing yeah it's not most most
of those levers and those tasks are not
full-time they're part-time and can
easily be contracted out so and to your
point right is if you can keep that
below the 12 people-ish Mark it's a
really nice forcing function to go I'm
not going to think about hiring as the
measure of success I'm going to think
about the levers that have to do with
profitability as the measures of success
and actually less head count is more
successful than more yeah yeah I think I
kind of fell into the same trap like a
year 18 months ago where you know
initially I was doing the YouTube thing
myself for two years and then I read the
email 3 visited and had a mentor who
encouraged me to hire and we got an
editor and we got a writer and it's like
oh my God incredible like so good having
like two three four people on the team
and then we were like Hey we're making
all this money through courses what if
we got like someone to help produce the
course it's cool five six seven people
on the team and then our cohort based
course really took off and suddenly we
had more money than I knew what to do
with it's like well all this millions
are selling in the business account
doing absolutely Jackal so let's hire
some people and that was a mistake the
mistake was
thinking that
there is a linear correlation between uh
a new employee doing a thing that
theoretically should contribute to
revenue and the real world of that thing
the communication and managerial
overheads associated with having an
extra person on the team
even if their thing is contributing to
revenue is it just the whole system
ended up slowing down
and I was in my mind trying to figure
out like Roi calculations for every
employee and all this kind of stuff and
it just turned into an absolute
nightmare yeah but most people most
people are not Revenue critical and that
that was one of the harder lessons for
me in that first business
so if you were to do it again would you
only hire full-timers who are Revenue
critical and then contract the rest or
like how would you be thinking about
that I would either do it as I would
keep it very very small like we hadn't
we had such an amazing business when it
was just five people yeah like and
looking back on that I was like I wish I
knew how good I had it at that moment
um because me and my co-founder were
essentially out of the business we had
Justin we had just enough people to run
it yeah and we could just oversee and
focus on bringing in new clients and we
didn't need a ton of clients because it
was a small team you know it was like it
was perfect
and so I would either do that again and
keep them full time and just and almost
operate at a deficit intentionally like
I'd rather have a wait list for clients
than constantly be like we need 10 new
clients a month you know so I would
either do that or I would go the
contractor route
um but same thing I would probably keep
it small and the thing that I try and
educate talented writers on is
you will probably make more so that
value of death you will probably make
more money just doing what you do
individually and scaling your your
pricing in a niche and being the best
person in that niche just working for
yourself you will probably make more
money you don't need an agency and
whenever someone
thinks about scaling themselves with an
agency I always try and stop them and
I'm like
you do not need this like you're
actually probably going to make the same
or less money because now you have other
people to take care of so if you're a
really talented writer you might as well
just work for yourself yeah it seems
like the agency game is becoming like uh
I feel like a few years ago if you
looked at the category of make money
online on YouTube Drop Shipping
affiliate marketing was all the rage
these days it's all about social media
marketing agencies yeah and there's like
a few kind of big YouTubers one of them
we have in the Pod a few months ago who
I have courses teaching people how to
set up agencies and stuff and
um young broad young and broke people
who watch these sorts of videos how to
make money on the internet are thinking
that an smma social media marketing
agency is like the the key to riches and
wealth
um but I think that that thing of like
the genuinely is like a value of death
between like one one and 10 million
where
things things start to break and there's
there's a Nuance here which is
you can be a one-person agency
right A lot of times the the agency
education is really just about
productizing your service and organizing
it and and you know you can have the
service and then you can scale it with
some digital products like and you can
do all of that as a one-person shop
that's fine the myth though is oh if I
hire more people my income just goes up
to the right that's not how it works and
your headaches go up and it Demands a
totally different skill set and you go
from being a writer or practitioner into
being a manager right your whole life is
different and so if that's what you want
go ahead and do it but if you're a
writer you're really great at a
specialty skill set you're better off
just scaling and increasing your
earnings and charging more and working
with higher and higher quality people
than you are going well let me scale
horizontally yeah you know I mean yeah
one of the one of the ways I think about
this which kind of really actually
helped shape a lot of decisions in the
business is that
if I won the lottery or if I took money
out of the equation how would I want to
be spending my time and I found that
like when we had 20 people on the
payroll the ways I was spending my time
were radically different to how I wanted
to be spending my time whereas now that
we have basically the same people but
like half of them are contractors and
the other half are employees now I'm
spending all my time doing the things I
actually want to be doing
um and I I find that this is a good
similarly I know I know people who just
really enjoy writing who I actually want
to do writing they don't want to manage
an agency of writers they want to do the
writing because it's fun right yeah I
was that person then it took me yeah it
was a hard lesson to learn like I don't
want to manage
20 writers you know I'm really good at
what I do I just want to be paid a
premium to do what I do
nice okay so so far we talked about kind
of five different ways to make seven
figures of the writer we talked about
um writing as a service like ghost
writing and how essentially by just
starting for free doing it for someone
really well they're going to throw money
at you and also throw referrals at you
because
you know it's just a thing in the world
of business that people who are
successful know other people who have
made made lots of money and who need the
same thing so that's just like easy and
easy enough in inverted commas we've
talked about productizing your service
and turning it into more of like well
agency slash digital products we talk
about sales copywriting we're like paid
paid newsletters what's the deal with
that paid newsletters are
they're both in an older category and
now it's being reinvented uh by sub
stack so all a paid newsletter is is
you just being paid for your ability to
scale
a certain type of
idea framework
um news whatever the benefit is to the
reader and so
when someone goes I'm going to start a
paid newsletter they think oh just
because it's a paid thing I'm going to
make money from it no that's not the
case that's like saying just because I
wrote a book people are going to buy it
people don't buy the asset right no one
buys a book no one buys a paid
newsletter what the person's buying is
an answer to a question they're buying a
certain type of outcome and the paid
newsletter is just a way of delivering
that or scaling that so to me there's
really only two types of paid
newsletters that work you either have
timely newsletters where the the benefit
is you're saving me time so you as the
newsletter Creator go out there and
you're gonna dig through all the
information you're gonna do the research
you're going to round up all the
statistics and the facts and you know
and you're I'm paying you to go do all
of that time and you're going to
compress it down for me and because
you're saving me so much time I'm going
to pay you for that like Trends exactly
yeah so that's that's one side of the
barbell and then the other side of the
barbell is the complete Ops set you go I
want access to
quote unquote Insider information I want
expert level insights so this person is
a domain expert they're going really
deep and you are it's almost like you're
paying to get the I want coffee with you
at scale right so someone's like I'm an
expert in this thing you pay me 10 bucks
a month 20 bucks a month whatever it is
and you're getting access to my
Frameworks my insights my and I'm going
to take you down the rabbit hole yeah
and that's the barbell you're either in
super timely or super Timeless and
shallow or deep and any newsletter that
sits in the middle like the biggest
mistake is people go subscribe to my
newsletter
nobody cares about your newsletter right
they care is this a trade for time I'm
paying you to save me time or is this a
trade for expertise I'm paying you to
shorten my growth currency yes so like
Ben Thompson the strategories world are
like the depth in-depth analysis on a
topic that this guy's been in for the
last 20 years totally and then the
trends of the world are like we've got a
team of researchers who are going to
research the best Trends and we're going
to save you time as an investor as a
business person to be able to see what
the market wants and that's the barbell
yes there are outliers but 99 of the
time successful paid newsletters fall
into one of those two categories and
again you have to start from the
thinking place of you are not writing
what you want to write about and then
charging for it you have to start from
the place of I am starting a business
called a paid newsletter business and
what am I in the business of doing
saving people time or giving people
expertise
those are the two businesses and you
need to be clear on which business you
want to start yeah and I guess a mistake
that that people make with this is
almost thinking of a paid newsletter as
sort of a patreon equivalent of like hey
you like my newsletter every week where
I share my my what's what I'm getting up
to in my life
you know as with some some percentage
feel free to support me kind of vibe
huge mistake yeah because nobody I mean
look it's not just creators who make
this mistake go go to any multi-billion
dollar company's website on the sidebar
they go subscribe to our newsletter
you're like why even free newsletters
can't get people to read it right
because the Val the value to the reader
isn't you have a newsletter the value is
which one is it you're saving me time or
you're saving me years and shortening my
growth curve
and so you going you know subscribe to
Ollie's newsletter right like yeah some
people might but that is not the lever
that makes the paid newsletter go yeah
yeah and I guess you know even in the
creative Zone if we think of like Tim
ferriss's five bullet Friday the way he
pitches it is that every Friday it's
just five things that I've curated
because I I come across interesting
things and I will save you time because
yeah which one is it and you can try you
can try these things out and that's not
even a paid newsletter it's just it's
just a free one
um and you can go the free route and
monetize with ads which is what he did
which is you know the hustle morning
Brew all like ads work but
subscription revenues King right and if
it doesn't take very much for you to go
okay if I can get a thousand people on
my paid newsletter like I'm
living yeah now you're making six
figures that's that's amazing like you
the math is it's it's not that hard to
make six figures as a writer on the
internet if
if you can unhook your thinking from I'm
writing what I want to write about and
people are going to pay me right you're
starting a business the business is
you're in the business of serving
readers with your writing and so the
only way like I think you can get to six
figures just fumbling around but the
only way that you're gonna get to Seven
is by being really clear which side of
the barbell are you on
yeah this is like a
I feel like I've only I've only recently
developed this appreciation of like
almost like the the difference between
six seven six figures and seven figures
because having like I've now been in
that zone for the last like many years
but I have zero
like at like zero experience at the
eight figure range and so when I speak
to like you know interviewed Alex
formosi and it was like oh well you know
six figures or single Channel single
Target single Avatar single product easy
seven figures blah blah blah easy I
suppose you get to five million
15 million is a lot harder because I'm
just like okay this is now a level of
knowledge that I just cannot even
appreciate because I'm kind of stuck in
the seven figure category myself and
similarly a lot of viewers or or
listeners
are stuck in the five figure category
where they've got a job and they they
aspire to get to six figures where I was
like oh my God if I could make six
figures doing what I love are you
writing for four hours a day hell yeah
sign me up yeah and then you get to that
point and it's like and you almost kind
of realize that
yeah this thing of
six figures it isn't that hard but seven
figures is it's like my current model
but someone like well MOSI might think
seven figures not that hard eight
figures maybe is and it's just like
different levels of experience get you
to different kind of number of zeros on
the end of your on the end of your
balance sheet totally yeah it's there's
different uh models and mental models
for each one and also it just depends on
which business you're in and are you are
you okay with the business that you
choose you know like for example I love
writing books
you can make millions of dollars writing
books but it's a lot easier to make
millions of dollars
providing a service or you know like
being a Ghostwriter as a service or
productizing yourself or building a
course or an education product so it's
possible to do all of these things it's
just
is it the thing that you actually want
to spend time doing and that to me is
the more important question you know
like are you playing the game that you
want to play yeah yeah I was I was
speaking to another um entrepreneur
friend the other day and
um I won a dilemma that I put to her was
that like yeah I feel like you know now
that we're you know this YouTube channel
is at least somewhat successful there's
all these like different ways of making
money and I just like don't really know
which like which ones we should be going
for and the analogy that she used was
like she was like oh you know the way I
think of this is that there's all these
different like money clouds in the air
and you can make any of them rain but
the point is you just want to figure out
which ones align with what you actually
want to do and your own values and then
you just ignore all the other 99 of them
and just actively decide these are the
ones I'm focusing on yeah
yeah it's sick cool so writing books how
does one make money through writing
books so the big the big question with
this is
self-publishing versus traditional
publishing so just for a little context
so most people don't know that a
conventional publishing deal goes like
this
they give you an advance that Advance is
predicated on your existing audience
right it's often not the quality of the
book it's your existing audience
and how the deal structure works is
they'll probably give you a we'll call
it
eight percent on the really low end 15
on the high end royalty so
the real way to think about it is the
advance they're giving you they're
buying 85 of your book
so imagine your book is a business an
investor comes along and goes I want to
buy into your business I'm going to take
85 percent and I'm going to give you
this advance
the advance for most people
I mean I'll say probably the average is
somewhere between 10 20K all the way to
maybe 100 maybe to 250 okay anything
above that you have a giant audience or
you're a celebrity yep like period and
anything below that the reason they're
giving you that is because your audience
is growing and they believe that you
will be bigger tomorrow than you are
today yeah so it's worth asking the
question if a publisher is willing to
give you that why are they willing to
give you that and if they're going to
give you 100K that means they think they
can make a million
so keep that in mind when you're you
know thinking about your deal the other
side of it is
self-publishing most people don't know
how easy self-publishing is you can do
print on demand on Amazon you upload
your book anyone can do that
every time a book gets sold you get your
share and if it's a print book all
Amazon does is they extract their
printing cost so say the printing cost
is three dollars so they're selling the
book for 10 they extract the three
because that's what it costs them to
print they ship it to the person and
then you get your split something like
65 percent you know or whatever it is
um
and that's how self-publishing works
and so there's a bit of an irony in the
sense that you are only going to get a
publishing deal if you have an audience
but if you have an audience you could
and should just self-publish because
you're going to make more money and it's
important to do the napkin math on
how many copies do you need to sell
if you're only getting 15 of every sale
or if you're getting 65 70 of every sale
on Amazon or a hundred percent on your
own site and after you do the math you
realize you need to sell like close to
10 times more books with a traditional
deal than if you just self-publish so
oftentimes you will make a lot more
money just self-publishing and the only
time in my opinion the only time you
should take a traditional publishing
deal is
there's three criteria there's it's
either a personal development book
it's a personal finance book
and you are swinging for I want to write
a New York Times bestseller Wall Street
Journal bestseller and by the way the
only way that you're going to hit that
list is probably if you're writing a
personal development book or a personal
finance book because that's the vast
majority right and even further if you
want a chance at hitting that that list
be prepared to spend a lot of your own
money as well so to me that's the only
time you should be playing that game is
like I've got everything in place I want
to swing for the fences I want to do
this thing right if not if you just want
to make money self-publish a lot of this
stuff like
I mean I guess maybe not ghost writing
sales copywriting prototyping your
service but certainly paid newsletter
and writing books and
certainly selling a course and stuff all
seem to be predicated on building an
audience
uh I know this is a huge ass question
but like how does one build an audience
with online writing what's the Playbook
the the starting point is if you want to
build an audience don't focus on
building an audience I mean the the
fallacy that people have is if a
gazillion people are following me
then I can do something
and that's really not how it works how
it works is you are consistently
delivering something that's valuable to
people and then they follow you as a
result right and so and and the other
point is just because you have a big
number of followers doesn't mean that
they're the right kind of followers
right it doesn't mean that they're the
people most likely to then go buy a
product or service right so if you
start by going I just want to build an
audience well if you build an audience
around one thing and then you go and
launch a product or service or business
that is unrelated to that those people
aren't going to convert right so if
you're just out here making memes
getting half a million followers then
you're like and here I'm starting a
ghostwriting company like there's going
to be a mismatch and so the whole key is
you want to take a this is like the
biggest thing that we share with people
in ship 30 which is you want to take a
data-driven approach the whole idea
behind digital writing is that you've
accelerated your feedback loop so Legacy
world of writing Hemingway sits down he
spends four years writing a novel sells
it to a publisher he has to wait another
18 months for it to get published and he
has to wait another 12 months for the
magazine reviews to come out and then he
has to go to a pub down the street and
then he overhears some person being like
Hemingway's novel was terrible right
that's the feedback loop whereas today
the feedback loop is I have an idea I
write a tweet a thread an atomic essay a
LinkedIn post I publish it and I get
feedback three minutes later
and if you do that and you constantly
take a data-driven approach every time
you write something you should be
learning who is this resonating with is
this something I want to keep writing
about every time you see a breakout data
point you go oh maybe I should double
down on that right and you just keep
accelerating your Niche over and over
and over again I'm sure as you've been
making videos over the years
you started to recognize oh when I make
this type of video the chart goes up and
to the right and when I make this type
of video it flatlines or it goes down
and intuitively you and every other
Creator goes I'm going to keep doing the
thing that's working right and so what
we try and educate people on is just
make that decision conscious right from
the very beginning notice what's working
and you can accelerate your feedback
loop and your growth curve by just
doubling down on the winners and cutting
the losers yeah we got this problem a
lot in our YouTube of course where
people get so hung up on what's my Niche
and I always try and like the way the
way I describe it it's like you know uh
uh the architect approach versus the
archaeologist approach or it's like an
architect
has the plans for the whole house before
they lay a single brick whereas or as an
archaeologist like kind of goes to one
site they do a bit of digging then they
go to another one go to another side and
then like oh [__] I've struck some gold
they'd keep on Excavating they they dig
some more and
unless you are for example a uh sort of
in in the world of YouTube a kind of
mattyavela where you've been making
documentaries about documentaries on
Netflix for 10 years and you already
know how to make a Bang video even then
he did a lot of archaeologisting to get
to his Niche or a Peter McKinnon where
it's like I've been a photographer
videographer for 10 years and now I'm
going to teach the thing at that point
maybe it makes sense to sort of come in
with like actively thinking like I'm
gonna stand out in the space of
Photography tutorials but for most other
people especially while you're learning
the craft and figuring things out like
you just gotta throw loads of spaghetti
at the wall dig in loads of sights and
the ones that seem to stick you double
down on those and kind of keep your mind
open it's the way we we call this lean
writing so just you acknowledging that
you are not the genius at the table
right just create data points and double
down on the winners it always looks
cleaner from the outside
but what most people don't know okay so
Ryan holiday is a great example Ryan
holiday was a marketer right and his
first book was about marketing and his
second or third book same thing was
about growth hacker marketing then he
goes and writes this blog post for Tim
Ferriss called stoicism 101. and the
blog post goes crazy and he gets all
these emails and he gets all this
feedback and data saying there's
something interesting about this so he
goes I'm going to double down on it and
he writes a book called the obstacles
the way he even tells the story he goes
I didn't get a very big advance for the
obstacles the way right because it was
new and it was an unproven data point
the publisher goes well we're valuing
you as a marketing writer and you want
to write about this new thing
and now he's the best selling most
well-known stoicism writer in the world
right so it looks really clean from the
outside they're like oh you constructed
this from the beginning that's not true
he literally just created a data point
saw that it won and doubled down on it
most people don't know the same thing
about Mark Manson yeah right Mark Manson
didn't sit down and go I'm going to
write this insanely amazing best-selling
book you know solar of not giving a [__]
right but
what happened is the publisher goes to
him and goes well you have a big blog
you have a big audience uh you should
write a book he goes great what should
it be about they go we don't know what's
your biggest most viral blog post he
goes well it's a blog post called the
subtle art I'm not giving a [__] right
and what did he do he just expanded the
blog post into a book there's so many
examples of lean writing out in the
world and it's just from the outside as
consumers we think it's this beautifully
orchestrated yeah everything's perfect
from the beginning it's not yeah yeah I
think I think the the other cool thing
there is that
even though Ryan holiday and Mark Manson
are like Deca millionaires by this point
from their various things still most
people have not heard of them yeah and
it's just like you know
I was I was at a dinner the other day
and I just casually throw the name
Jordan Peterson and like other people
like who's that I was like what come on
and when I mentioned Ryan holiday like
amongst like normal people like almost
no one has heard of him yeah and it's
just like this guy's like stupidly
successful and is like making tons and
tons and tons of money doing the thing
that he loves and working four hours a
day and spending time with his family
and his farm Deca millionaire probably
had like most people haven't heard of
him which is a very like uh a comforting
thought that you don't actually need to
be like Ed Sheeran levels of famous to
to make loads of money and have a really
successful career I was gonna say
there's there's a positive takeaway from
that which is you don't need that many
people
paid newsletter great example right you
don't need that many people to start
making six figures as a writer you know
if you're self-publishing books you
don't need that many people buying your
book for it to start being really
profitable for you so that's part of
what I love again no one educated me on
that I had to figure a lot of this out
on my own but what I love sharing with
other writers is realizing that you
don't need to be JK Rowling to live an
awesome life you know you don't need to
be this insanely best-selling I smash
all these records success is a lot
easier if you just focus on a small
number of people focusing on solving
their problems answering their questions
and using writing as the vehicle for
scaling that information so let's say
someone's listening to this and they're
like cool I want to get started with
writing online
um
and they might have come across the
advice that I was actually peddling a
few years ago of like start a blog
how do you feel about starting a blog
these days my favorite my favorite
question
um blogging is
the digital equivalent of being a legacy
writer you know it's you think again
what is a Blog it's your website you
think you're the important part there's
a saying I love repeating to uh writers
in chip 30 which is you are not the main
character of your story the reader is
the main character nice I like that the
moment you realize that you realize that
you are in the business of serving the
reader right that is literally what you
are being paid to do and so a Blog it's
like well what is that it's the writer
going I'm super special here's my fonts
here's my website here's my writings
here's my color scheme here's my
pictures right the reader doesn't care
about any of that point a they care
about what you can do for them point B
is there's no distribution flywheel
so how is anyone going to find your
writing the only people who know your
about your website or your blog or your
mom and your dog right
so it's you have no mechanism to get in
front of readers I mean I guess I guess
the kind of the I think people might be
thinking if they're in legacy mode is
well if I write enough eventually either
people will share it and quote it'll go
viral through sharing or I'll get
traffic through Google yeah so okay so
okay I'm feeding you basically yeah yeah
it's just like a layup right so what is
traffic through Google you know the only
way that you're gonna rank who's going
to rank for productivity on Google
is it going to be you or is it going to
be Forbes
right or is it going to be skillshare or
udemy right when
Google is a search mechanism that
businesses spend an insane amount of
time energy and money to own
you are never going to outrank udemy for
productivity it's just not going to
happen and most writers again this is
where it's like you have to slow down
and really understand what goal are you
working toward if you are so the vast
majority of writers they sit down they
go I want to write something okay so you
just want to write and then you want to
reach certain people okay great what is
seo seo is the complete opposite of that
SEO is there's a search term and I want
to own that search term and I don't even
care how the writing turns out I just
want to own that search term two
completely different goals so again it's
a fallacy where people go if I just
write on my blog I'm going to rank on
Google you don't even know what that
means you're not going to rent what are
you gonna rank for right so it's like
that's part of I feel like I'm on this
Quest you know and I have to like walk I
have to run around with the flag and be
like try and educate every writer be
like what you were told is wrong and let
me explain to you why it's wrong and let
me show you a different way because so
many writers it's not that they're not
talented it's just they either were
taught to think about it the wrong way
or in my case you're told you can't make
a living as a writer there's never been
a better time in history to make a
living as a writer you just have to
understand how to make money as a writer
okay so website is a no-go website
should you have a website at all like
well so you can have a website
and it's I think it's fine to treat it
as a like this is where my best work
lives you know but again don't be
confused it's gonna be way easier for
you to get millions of views on your
writing if you're publishing on Twitter
LinkedIn quora medium you know anywhere
that there's a social Garden where lots
of people are hanging out the way that I
like to explain it is think of it like
you go to a party downtown in the city
that's we're in London there's a there's
a pub and the pubs there's people
spilling out of the pub you know and
it's an amazing time and you walk up
there and you're Whispering into every
person's ear and you're like hey I throw
really great parties too you should come
back to my flat uh trust me it's amazing
every time you show up with a blog post
that's what you're doing you're like hey
I throw really great parties too and
everyone's like no I want to stay at the
pub it's amazing here right everyone
wants to stay in Twitter everyone wants
to stay in LinkedIn so you should be
writing in the environment and then sure
your site is where your best work can
live but that's not what's going to
drive the result okay so right on
Twitter right on LinkedIn
am I just okay so let's say I'm writing
on LinkedIn and I'm like okay so firstly
how do I decide Twitter versus LinkedIn
versus quora versus medium I know this
kind of changes over time but right now
they go through different uh Peaks and
valleys but both either are great uh
Twitter and Linkedin I think have the
best distribution right now
um but it doesn't to me it doesn't
really matter either or I love when
people go I don't think my Niche exists
here it's like there's hundreds of
millions of people on these platforms it
exists it's just you haven't figured out
yet how to reach people which leads to
the second question fallacy which then
the person goes yeah but I can't reach
them unless I have an audience okay
social platforms have changed people
don't understand how a social platform
works it doesn't matter if you have a
hundred thousand followers or you have
10 followers what happens every time you
write something is a social platform
feeds it to a small number of people so
it goes we're going to show this to 25
people
and based on the ratio based on the
number of people in that small group
that interact if it is above the
majority we're going to show it to more
people and if it's below we're not going
to show it to as many people so that's
how you have someone who you know you me
anyone who has a larger following it
doesn't matter if you have 100K
followers 100K people aren't seeing your
content the only way that it's getting
distributed is if the thing that you
wrote keeps crossing the next threshold
where the platform goes this is worth
being shown to more people which means
everyone's on a Level Playing Field you
don't need a huge audience it's just
about the quality of what you're
creating
how do you figure out what to create
like someone listening to this is like
oh okay so I guess I should I should
write on Twitter what what the hell am I
going to write on Twitter or LinkedIn so
we have a there's a really great like
beginner framework that we uh share with
people uh right in the first week of
ship 30 which we call for who so that
so every time you sit down to write
who are you creating for
so that they can do what
okay so before you write a single word
at the top of your page you should write
for who so that okay so
for who so this is writing advice for
beginners so that they can outcome
outcome outcome so that they can build
an audience accumulate tens of millions
of views make their first dollar online
right and if you just start from the
four who so that
over and over again you're in great
territory and the thing that I is
important to remind people is
it's not that you make that decision
once and then that's the only thing you
can do this is not a marriage decision
right seven years ago I was writing
about bodybuilding on the internet
nobody cares now that's fine you can
change over time but if you start every
single thing that you create with the
four who sew that framework then you can
test different audiences you can test
different outcomes and then you take
that data-driven lean writing approach
and you go well every time I write for
who so that here it performs well and
every time I write four who saw that
over here it doesn't perform well well
what should you do we'll double down on
my winner cut my loser right and all of
a sudden it removes all this pressure of
you have to sit down and be the genius
in the room and go what's your niche
just let the data tell you right the
data told Ryan holiday stoicism is where
the opportunity is the data told Mark
Manson hey you know life advice and the
subtle art of not giving a [__] is where
the opportunity is just follow the data
yeah
yeah I guess at that point people like
I've got a question that I often get is
that but what if I don't like what the
data tells me what if like what if I
don't want to Panda panda to the
audience kind of thing and like what if
I actually do want to do all this other
these other things that I'm more
interested in
you can do that yeah you know it's like
again you have the freedom
and an important thing to remember is
just because something performs well
doesn't mean you have to do that
so I've written things that have gone
viral that then the next day I was like
that's cool but that's not really what I
want to write about okay great
push it to the side create some new data
points see what happens right that's
again it's not a marriage decision you
can keep experimenting you can keep
evolving yeah I have a friend who is
doing this kind of method with her
YouTube channel and she's been kind of
throwing some spaghetti to the walls
seeing what sticks double down on the
stuff that sticks while still kind of
doing a little bit more spaghetti
throwing uh and she had a video go viral
on a topic that she didn't really she
was like uh I mean the video's gone
viral but like I actually don't think I
want to make videos on that particular
topic but the concern is
have I I have now gained an audience of
like 10 000 extra like 25 of my
subscriber count is now has now come
from that video so therefore like
am I kind of shooting myself in the foot
by
ignoring that that segment of the market
and I guess I I kind of had this quick
problem when I like a year into my
YouTube channel I made a video about how
I take notes on my iPad Pro and all of a
sudden half my subscribers were from
that from that one video and I was like
damn I used to be a how to get into med
school Channel and now I'm a freaking
tech tech YouTuber what the hell is
going on there and often found this
struggle between like trying to imagine
the mass of the audience and be like Oh
but like some of them are like
kind of 13 year old girls doing their
like School exams and wanting to learn
how to study a bit harder and be
motivated and the other 38 year old Tech
bro is wanting to learn about the latest
iPad what the hell is going on like how
would you approach that kind of thing
yeah there's that's why so much of this
is like being exposed to different ways
of thinking because these are all just
decisions
one of the things that quora taught me
and I love this framework is the size of
the question dictates the size of the
audience
so for example
how big is the audience of person who
wants to get into med school that is way
smaller than the size of audience that
goes how can I improve my note-taking
ability right so the size of the
question dictates the size of the
audience so when you see a data point
it's worth keeping in mind well so like
what's the category difference like of
course personal development is always
probably going to outperform something
like how to get into med school or
something that's more Niche and so
that's why part of the data and again
this is a big thing that we teach people
in ship 30 is part of the data is not
more views equals better hmm right it
also you have other data points like
what are the quality of comments like I
know every time I write personal
development I'm going to get more views
and the comments are going to be like
nice hmm
good one this was really helpful you
know whereas every time I write about
ghost writing or how to start a a
business by writing on the internet I'm
going to get less views but I'm going to
get way higher quality comments and
people asking me questions and again you
can do both and so it's you have to like
learn how to read the data and go okay
well this one's getting a little more
attention but this one's getting me more
engagement you can have both yeah but
which one is connected to your business
which one is driving the outcome that
you want yeah and I guess like almost a
third data point is how did you feel
writing about those things totally like
I don't care about talking about medical
school admissions anymore but I used to
seven years ago when I made money off
the back of that right and now it's just
like what else yeah I guess like you
don't really care to write about
bodybuilding anymore exactly even if it
maybe started to do well you'd be like
hey actually this is interesting yeah
and you have to you want to do the thing
you're always going to be more
successful when you do the thing that
you actually want to do so that's why
again you kind of have to divorce
yourself from the well just because it's
getting more views doesn't mean that
it's better you know what's I I like
thinking of it as which is connected to
your business right if if your business
is like YouTube although it changes with
CPM and stuff but like with YouTube it's
more views equals more money right so I
would understand someone going I want to
optimize for views Mr Beast makes very
strategic decisions to optimize four
views right but if your business is I
you know I want to teach you how to
start writing online or I want to teach
you how to become a ghost writer right
you actually don't care about views
views is a pointless metric I care
whether people are engaging commenting
what questions do they have am I
answering the right questions am I
moving those people into some sort of
Education that's going to help them yeah
right so you have to understand which
metric and which lever is tied to the
actual business that you're in yeah and
I guess when you what do you do when
you're starting out where you don't yet
have that business
you just test data points right because
what I always like paying attention to
is so views and and likes is kind of
which way is the wind blowing is there
interest in this direction or this
direction but comments are where you
really start seeing what people need
help with so one of the big things I
like pointing out to people is if one
person comments on your video with a
question
the average person or the average
Creator just goes oh someone commented
and then they like walk away and do
whatever but that one question is your
first potential customer
DM them talk to them ask them what do
you need help with and if you just start
interacting with those people they're
literally going to tell you the business
to build because they're literally
saying if you just solve this problem I
will give you money
what do you I'm just throwing random
questions at you here because this is
great um what do you think are like
um Okay so
if someone has a field of expertise like
you I mean at this point you've been
writing for 10 plus years and so it's
easy enough for you to give advice on
writing what if someone listening to
this is maybe I don't know early 20s
just graduated universities started
their first job and feels like I don't
really have any skills I don't really
have any passions I guess I I go home
and like watch TV but like as everyone
else does like what like how do I figure
out what but but they want to build this
business on on the internet and there's
this sort of gap between like where
they're at and seeing people who are
experts
allegedly sharing opinions on stuff
where they feel like they don't have any
expertise to share opinions on stuff hmm
so uh in ship 30 we call this the
two-year test although it can also be
the two-day test or two hour test you
know when you were in fourth grade you
didn't want to learn from people who
were in college people who were in
college seemed like adults to you you
know they seemed like your parents who
you wanted to learn from was the fifth
grader because you were like hey what's
fifth grade like you wanted to learn
from a person who's just a little bit
ahead of you and so when you're thinking
about things to share you want to use
this two we call it the two-year test
where it's what are all the things that
you've learned over the past two years
what are all the experiences you've had
what are all the pivotal moments what
are the lessons you know the mistakes
the tips you would give right and all
you're doing is you are creating for the
version of yourself two years ago you
are the fifth grader telling the fourth
grader here's what you can expect right
and if you just do that that is the cure
for imposter syndrome imposter syndrome
is you trying to do the two-year test
forward you're like I'm gonna pretend
I'm two years in the future you're not
there yet right your ideal reader or
viewer or listener is two years behind
you or two hours behind you what did you
just learn how to do great turn around
and pass it to the person who doesn't
know how to do that thing yet that's the
easiest solution yeah it's it's great
how a lot of the this stuff really
converges on the YouTube advice as well
it's the same thing like like the thing
I tell people is like if if you're
struggling with your Niche figure out
what have you learned in the last three
years or five years or ten years
depending on how old you are
um that you could potentially teach to
someone who's in that position and so
even now even though like with me I I
get emails from people in their 30s and
40s and 50s and stuff being like Oh
people coming up to the street of all
ages
um saying that your videos are helpful
I find it very hard to imagine what I
could possibly say that would be useful
to a 45 year old kids because it's like
what the hell do I know about
productivity from people with kids and I
just still just imagine myself speaking
to someone who's like 25.
um but there's that thing I think in in
12 immutable laws marketing that that
the target is not the market like you
can speak to one person but actually
your Market could be a lot bigger than
that yeah I mean it's a it's a great
sales copywriting adage which is if you
write something for everyone you write
something for no one you know you
your goal is to write or create
something that is so specific it's
Universal to all the people that are
like that person
so whenever you're thinking of I want to
build an audience you shouldn't think of
a massive people you should think of one
person what is their name where do they
live what problems do they have what are
they interested in and if you're clear
about that you're going to attract all
the other people who are like that
person but if you just think I want to
build an audience you're in the mindset
of how do I get everyone
first of all the more you try and get
everyone the more you get no one second
of all you don't need everyone so what
you were saying you don't need Ed
Sheeran level of success right you just
need a thousand people it's the famous
essay a thousand true fans or Legion I
think was the one who wrote a hundred
true fans right you just you don't need
as many people as you think
yeah it's like um I often when when
people ask about this Niche thing uh
there's a story that Tim Ferriss told
where he was like he really struggled
with writing the four-hour work week and
then he decided to write it in a Gmail
compose window to like two of his
friends exactly that just made it so
easier so much easier because it feels
like you're writing to a single person
rather than trying to imagine a well
analytics tell me my audience is like 15
to 54 living in like the UK the US
Australia India China yeah
how do you even begin to imagine that is
exactly what quora taught me is quora
was literally one person saying I have
this question and what did Cora do it
scaled my answer to that one person's
question to everyone else who had that
question so you would have quora answers
get millions and millions of views but
it started by answering one person's
question and then the platform scaled it
to everyone else and Twitter is the same
linkedin's the same medium's the same
yep every platform YouTube's the same
you start with the one person's question
and then the platform's responsible for
Distributing it which is what your blog
doesn't do yeah
um importance of having your own email
list question mark
so
again depends on what your goal is
like you can have a successful freelance
writing or ghost writing business
without an email list you can have a
successful YouTube channel without an
email list but soon as you start getting
into productizing yourself a paid
newsletter is inherently a list or like
writing and selling a book you want to
have some sort of list because you want
to be able to reach those people
directly I think the biggest mistake
authors make is they go I'm going to set
out to write a book and they have no
attention engine they have no social
following they have no email list you
need some way of interacting with
readers because the book otherwise is
just gonna sit on the bookshelf with you
know millions and millions and millions
of other titles no one's just going to
pluck your book off the shelf yeah nice
so would it be a case of like like again
let's say someone is someone is a total
beginner to this would you recommend
they start off
like email list from day one and funnel
people from their Twitter bio into the
email list or like try it out for a few
years it's like at what point would you
start to think about the email list the
email list is an inflection point and
it's a decision after you've clarified
your writing in Social environments so
you've written consistently you've
generated a bunch of data points you've
learned what works you have a clear
understanding of who you're trying to
reach and help what questions they have
and then the newsletter is just the more
of that right so social is the I do it
in x amount of words I go into like a
certain level of depth the newsletter is
I'm going to do that for the same type
of person just way more and again then
you have the barbell decision am I
saving you time or am I giving you
expert level insight and the reality is
most people especially when they're
getting interested in something you
don't have the expert level Insight so
go the other route right curate save
people time be the one who's researching
you are now getting copied compensated
to learn and build your skills and over
time if you want to you can translate
over to now I am an expert nice to what
extent can people quote like
expect a growth on thing like if we if
we take Twitter for example
you know the thing I tell people for
YouTube is do the one video every week
for two years and I guarantee that'll
change your life but I can't put any
numbers on it I can't tell you whether
you'll get 10K 100K a million followers
or even if you'll get monetized at all
but I can just tell you it'll change
your life and that kind of more like
long-term thinking without really being
wedded to a particular outcome is at
least how I approach the YouTube stuff
how do you think about that for I guess
Twitter LinkedIn yeah I mean so if we
really want to talk about it as a like
hedge on your time energy and effort
the best
the best measure for success in writing
online is just thinking about building
your library so every time someone comes
to you with a question every time
someone goes hey what do you think about
X
notice how often you repeat yourself so
when you go have a coffee meeting how
many times do you say the same tidbits
about yourself how many times do you
explain well this is my thought process
on making videos this is how I think
about solving these problems right every
time you're saying that you are manually
doing the work writing online or making
videos or having a podcast is your
ability to scale that in the sense where
now every time someone asks you that
question you don't have to repeat
yourself you go I I already wrote about
it over here so remove the audience
remove the how many followers remove the
email list remove the money
even still just creating things on the
internet allows you to scale yourself
digitally so then the question just goes
do you think that there's benefit in
scaling yourself on the internet
everyone's gonna go well yeah of course
there is because now you have a library
that you can point to over and over and
over again that's like the greatest
hedge on it all it's not wasted time or
effort what sort of success stories have
you seen from people that you know who
have done the writing online thing oh
huge I mean we have tons coming out of
ship 30 now where it's like they take
the Frameworks we have so many people
who have built audiences bigger than me
on Twitter
that's best case scenario I love seeing
that because then that proves hey these
things that were teaching they work you
just have to put them into place and you
know we've had people get tens of
millions of views insanely viral Twitter
threads build audiences of 100K 200k
300K launch their own products start
making money on the internet made their
first five grand 10 grand 20 grand 50
Grand like it all
it is all possible but for me the reason
why
like someone can build a bigger audience
faster than me
almost always has to do with the
category they're playing in right so for
me if my business is writing education
I don't care if I have 50k followers or
100K or 200k I care about what is the
conversion rate of the number of people
who come in they learn about these
Frameworks and then they come over and
decide to participate in the business
right if someone else goes I want to
write about personal finance or I want
to write about personal development you
can easily build an audience 10 times
bigger than me and that's fine but I
hope that you connect it to a business
that's related to that audience right so
it all depends on what game you want to
play and how are you measuring that
success but it's all of this stuff is
you know when I was in school
my teachers which I always found weird
and ironic but they always said not
everyone can become a writer and I kind
of sat in class and I was like well then
why are we all here and I think Legacy
writing has this elitism to it where
it's like not everyone can do it and you
have to suffer and you have to stack
rejection letters and you know you're
you only are rewarded if you're
brilliant and like it's there's all this
red tape and the world of digital
writing now is anyone can become a
writer all of these skills are easy to
learn and it's possible you just need to
invest the time to learn some of these
skills and put them into practice
fantastic
cool thank you so much I think this is a
good place to end this there's still so
much to talk about category design your
uh next time there's no snow leopards
and all that kind of stuff which I I
read recently which is sick oh cool um
yeah where can people learn more about
your work and people find you uh Twitter
is probably the easiest uh uh point now
Nicholas call 77
um my I see I don't even Point people to
my website there you go and uh and if
anyone wants to start writing online
take uh the next cohort of ship 30 for
30. good stuff and we'll put links to
all of those in the video description
and perhaps you could even hook us up
with a discount code or something nice
we'll put all of that in the video
description and the show notes wherever
you're watching or listening to this so
we'll definitely do a round two next
time we're in the same geographical
location again uh I'm planning to visit
the us sometime in the new year so we'll
we'll hook up let me know we'll get
Dicky together we'll do in Miami that'll
be so good um thank you so much this has
been wonderful thanks man cheers all
right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye